ist Alexander Dobrindt der Vorsitzende
der CSU Landesgruppe
von anderen Themen in ihrer Rede
erheblich wundern es scheint ja manches
durcheinander gegangen zu sein wenn sie
davon reden dass jetzt endlich
Freihandelsabkommen abgeschlossen werden
ceta kommt jetzt ein Freihandelsabkommen
mit der USA wird jetzt gemacht und
erblicken Sie mal in diese rein kein
einziger Hand bei der SPD hat sich
bewegt und da kommen sie auf den
Gedanken es lag an der Union dass wir
diese heiraten nicht haben lieber Herr
dürr
man muss sich mit ihrer Rede weiter
beschäftigen weil sie ja ganz
offensichtlich vieles durcheinander
bringen sie verwechseln wir auch
Fortschritt in der fortschrittskoalition
mit ganz offensichtlicher Verschleierung
sie reden von der Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse im nächsten Jahr das Geld
dafür beschaffen Sie sich in diesem Jahr
sie reden von
rekordinvestitionen ein wesentlicher
Teil 10 Milliarden das ist der
fdp-beitrag zur Rentenversicherung ihre
aktienrente sie reden von soliden
Finanzen schaffen aber einen
Schattenhaushalt nach den anderen sie
geben dem Wort Schattenkabinett eine
ganz neue Bedeutung hätte
so sie verwechseln Fortschritt mit
Verschleierung und übrigens die
verwechseln auch Investitionsquote mit
illusionsquote das ist die Realität in
ihrem Haushalt
und sehr geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler sie
bedienen sich hier wenn wir schon bei
Illusionen sind sie bedienen sich hier
alles im Wunderland was groß ist ist
klein was klein ist ist groß zu ihren
ihre Worte mir fehlt ehrlich bei dieser
Bundesregierung nur eins ein Jim Knopf
und der Scheinriese je näher man ihrer
Bundesregierung kommt umso kleiner
werden ihre politischen Leistungen das
ist die Realität
der Bundeskanzler sie haben hier am
Rednerpult vorhin betont sie wollen und
Sie werden zwei Prozent in die
Verteidigung investieren das Problem ist
doch nur sie machen es nicht der
Bundeskanzler sie haben gesagt es müssen
erst Maschine angeschafft werden damit
überhaupt irgendwas produziert werden
kann ja geht es eigentlich noch kleiner
in der Argumentation ihr für ihre
Verteidigungsministerin hat bei den
Verhandlungen zu den 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen zugesagt dass sie noch in
diesem Jahr 10 Milliarden an Munition
beschaffen wird keine einzige Patrone
ist bisher bestellt worden das Problem
der Bundeskanzler sind nicht die
fehlenden Maschinen in Deutschland
sondern die fehlende Führung in ihren
Verteidigungsministerium das ist es geht
bei der Einbringung dieses Haushalts der
Bundeskanzler am 7 september haben sie
uns noch sehr bescheiden mitgeteilt dass
sie die energieversorgungsprobleme
bereits gelöst hätten bevor wir sie
überhaupt erkannt hätten wie ihre Lösung
ausschaut das sagt uns vorgestern ihr
Behördenchef der Netzagentur Klaus
Müller auf Twitter ich zitiere wörtlich
keine Panik so kann es tatsächlich zu
Stromabschaltungen im Winter kommen doch
diese dürfen meist vorab angekündigt
werden und maximal vier Stunden dauern
sehr geehrter Bundeskanzler vier Stunden
blick-erklärung ihre Energiepolitik
Frau Kollegin dröge sie haben hier
vorhin als Vorsitzender einer
Regierungsfraktion wie sie sich ja
zurecht benannt haben davon gesprochen
dass ab dem Jahr 2023 keine Gasheizungen
mehr eingebaut werden dürfen an welcher
Stelle dieses Koalitionsvertrag steht
das eigentlich ich kann Ihnen nur sagen
ich habe es nicht gefunden vielleicht
sollten Sie das mal aufklären entweder
war diese Aussage frei erfunden oder Sie
haben gerade eine ganze Branche in die
Insolvenz geschickt das ist ein
grundlegender Fehler
gehen Sie hier begangen haben
korrigieren Sie das bitte an dieser
Stelle und meine Damen und Herren dass
die Lage so dramatisch am Energiemarkt
ist das haben wir in den letzten Tagen
und Wochen intensivst ja auch diskutiert
übrigens auch mit unseren Nachbarländern
weil wir auf Strom Lieferungen dieser
Nachbarländer angewiesen sind sie haben
allerdings sie Habeck eine ganz
offensichtlich hohe Bereitschaft unsere
europäischen Partner vor den Kopf zu
stoßen das schafft kein zusätzliches
Vertrauen sie haben den letzten Monaten
mit der Übernahme von Juniper auch
unternehmerische Verantwortung für die
Energiepolitik in Deutschland übernommen
und sie haben unternehmerische
Verantwortung für die Energiepolitik in
anderen europäischen Ländern damit
übernommen die Schweden Weißfisch Weise
setzen neben der Wasserkraft und anderen
erneuerbaren Energien weiter auf die
Kern Energie uniper betreibt dort in
Schweden auch die Kernkraftwerke der Bau
eines weiteren Kernkraftwerks das in
Schweden geplant ist wurde jetzt von
Juniper aus Deutschland heraus
öffentlich abgesagt und Herr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister die
schwedische Energieministerin Epper
Busch wurde zu keinem Zeitpunkt von
ihnen darüber informiert wenn das der
Umgang mit unseren europäischen Partnern
ist dann schaffen sie kein
zusammenwachsen in Europa sondern sie
isolieren Deutschland energiepolitisch
in Europa
sehr geehrter Herr
Bundesfinanzminister sie haben hier in
ihrer Haushaltsrede am 8 September
gesagt ich zitiere Inflation bekämpft
man nicht mit immer neuen Staatsschulden
sondern nur dadurch dass man zurück zur
Seriosität und Solidität findet diese
Aussage ist richtig aber zwischen ihrer
Rede und dem heutigen Tag liegen
250 Milliarden Euro weitere neue
Schulden und die Inflationsrate ist von
7,9 auf 10,4 Prozent gestiegen die Ampel
hat jetzt 550 Milliarden neue Schulden
aufgenommen das ist der Schuldenstand
den alle Bundesländer zusammen seit der
Gründung der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
geschaffen haben das ist die Realität
die hier im Haushaltsansatz
so und dabei sagen sie nach wie vor
nicht genau für was sie dieses Geld und
zu welchem Zeitpunkt Sie dieses Geld
nehmen Anspruch nehmen wollen Sie
bauen einen großen schuldensack auf in
ihrem Keller des Finanzministeriums und
Glauben offensichtlich daran dass er in
den nächsten Monaten da unbehelligt
stehen wird schauen Sie sich doch bitte
mal ihre
Koalitionspartner an das ist wie mit dem
Hund und dem wurstvorrat das kann an
dieser Stelle bei definitiv nicht gut
geht und deswegen rate ich Ihnen
dringend kehren Sie zur Solidität zurück
nehmen Sie doch Ihre eigene Worte ernst
und vertrauen sie doch nicht ihren
Koalitionspartner dass sie ihr Geld hat
im Keller zufrieden lassen
[Applaus]
sie haben den ihrer Rede gestern der
Bundesfinanzminister deutlich gemacht
dass sich diese Bundesregierung
entschieden hätte keine Steuererhöhungen
vorzunehmen dass irritiert jetzt etwas
weil wir zurzeit Hochkonjunktur bei den
Notaren erleben in Vorbereitung ihres
Jahressteuergesetzes bei dem zu erwarten
ist dass erbschafts- und
Schenkungssteuern für Immobilien massiv
erhöht werden sie haben in ihrer Rede
dazu definitiv nichts gesagt ich kann
Ihnen sagen die Angst ist berechtigt und
sie ist groß ein erbrechtsexperte hat
jetzt auch nachgerechnet dass bei dem
vererben oder verschenken eines Hauses
die Erbschaftssteuer deutlich ansteigt
bei einem Wertanstieg von 61% führt das
dazu
dass das Häuschen das bisher für 10.000
Euro verschenkt vererbt worden ist jetzt
60.000 Euro neue
schenkungssteuerbedarf sehr geehrter
Herr Bundes Finanzminister wir brauchen
keine Steuererhöhungen auf Immobilien
durch die Hintertür wir brauchen hohe
Freibeträge damit keine Erbschaftssteuer
beim Übergang von Immobilien stattfindet
und deswegen sage ich Ihnen an dieser
Stelle da zitiere ich ihren
Parteikollegen Kubicki der Spaß hört
jetzt endlich auf die SPD fordert hier
die Vermögensabgabe die Grünen fordern
die Steuererhöhungen und das
Finanzministerium das ist für die
Erbschaftssteuer zuständig das ist eine
Grund falsche Aufstellung dieser
Regierung wir brauchen endlich die
Freibeträge damit es zu keinen
steuerhöhungen durch die hinter dir Gott
die Leute haben gerechtigt Angst davor
dass Immobilien nicht vererbt werden
können weil sie ihnen in die Tasche
greifen wollen das ist die Wahrheit
dieser Politik dieser Bundesregierung
Alexander Dobrindt ist Vorsitzender der
CSU-Landesgruppe und erster
stellvertretender Vorsitzender der
Unionsfraktion hat hier mancherlei
Angriffe gerichtet in Richtung Christian
Dörr Richtung Lindner Christian Lindner
und wir können feststellen Union und FDP
werden in absehbarer Zeit zumindest
keine besonders dicken Freunde werden
wenn man diesen Worten hier folgt
ansonsten ein Feuerwerk der Vergleiche
heute in der Generaldebatte auch viel
Kinder und Jugendliteratur die hier
zitiert wird wir sind gespannt wie es
weitergeht alles im Wunderland haben wir
schon gehört Jim Knopf jetzt aber
erstmal Rolf Mütze nicht der Vorsitzende
der SPD-Fraktion
wir leben in extremen und anstrengenden
Zeiten und der von Präsident Putin
wissentlich und willentlich entfachte
Krieg ist die schlimmste Form extremer
Politik aber auch das abgleitendes
stabiler Demokratien oder die Leugnung
des Klimawandels sind folgen und zeugen
von Radikalität und Ignoranz und
deswegen meine Damen und Herren in
diesem Umfeld wächst die Versuchung zu
extremen politischen Debatten leider
auch bei uns und ich denke wir
DemokratInnen und Demokraten müssen uns
diesen Extremismus entgegenstellen meine
Damen und Herren
weil nämlich die Wirklichkeit komplex
ist müssen wir den vereinfachen mit
unserer Fähigkeit zur Vernunft und zum
Kompromiss begegnen
regorismus ist Gift für den notwendigen
Zusammenhalt und für eine kluge Politik
Besonderheit Pluralismus und ein
Höchstmaß an Freiheit und Gerechtigkeit
sind die Voraussetzungen für den inneren
und äußeren Frieden meine Damen und
Herren Deutschland
hat hierbei eine wichtige Rolle und
natürlich auch eine Koalition so
unterschiedlicher Parteien deshalb
müssen wir und davon bin ich überzeugt
die einzigartige Chance nutzen in einem
Bündnis
gleichberechtigter Parteien wollen wir
unsere gemeinsamen Anliegen für Freiheit
Gerechtigkeit und Nachhaltigkeit bündeln
und einlösen mit Augenmaß und dem Sinn
für neue Realitäten das ist der Auftrag
für eine Koalition des Fortschritts und
wir sind stolz mit Olaf Scholz an der
Spitze daran mitwirken zu dürfen meine
Damen und Herren und die Gesetzgebung
und die Gesetzgebung der letzten Monate
und eben um was es heute hier geht der
neue Haushalt ergänzen sich das ist eine
kluge Politik und der
Bundesfinanzminister hat zum Abschluss
der Haushaltsberatung zur
Bereinigungssitzung die Haushälterinnen
und Haushälter würde mich recht im Sinne
als interessantes Völkchen bezeichnete
ich nehme an daraus klingt Sympathie und
Unterstützung und Respekt ich will
einfach sagen es sind selbstbewusst und
kompetente Abgeordnete ausgestattet mit
dem Vertrauen des Souveräns die noch mal
31 Milliarden Euro bewegt haben meine
Damen und Herren eben weil wir uns auf
nachhaltige öffentliche Güter wie Arbeit
wohnen Bildung und Mobilität
konzentrieren hat es sich gelohnt diesen
Haushalt noch mal zu verbessern und ich
bin der festen Überzeugung dass dieser
Haushalt uns auch gut durch das neue
Jahr tragen wird aber gleichzeitig
schafft diese Haushalt eben auch die
Voraussetzung für den Umbau der
Wirtschaft für eine klimaneutrale
Produktion für neue und gut bezahlte
Arbeitsplätze und gleichzeitig eben auch
für Ideen bei diesen Herausforderungen
meine Damen und Herren müssen sehr
vorankommen und im Vergleich
zu den vielen Jahrhunderten vor uns wo
der Strukturwandel immer über
Gesellschaften hereingebrochen ist haben
wir diesmal die einzigartige Chance
diesem Strukturwandel vorab ein Weg zu
geben einen Pfad und das ist auch die
Konsequenz und der Auftrag an diese
Koalition wir können ein modernes
Deutschland schaffen dass sich in den
nächsten Jahrzehnten auch in einem neuen
internationalen Umfeld behaupten kann
und muss aber meine Damen und Herren
natürlich ist diese Agenda
überlagert von einem brutalen Krieg
insbesondere gegen die Zivilbevölkerung
aber bei unserem Innern
hervorgerufen eine Energiekrise und eben
auch ein wachsenden Kaufkraftverlust
aber es ist unbestritten dass wir eben
die Ukraine die so brutal und mit Lügen
aufgebaut angegriffen worden ist
unterstützen müssen ja mit Waffen und
gleichzeitig aber auch mit humanitärer
Hilfe und einer finanziellen
Unterstützung die schon vor den Krieg
von Seiten Deutschland sehr groß
geworden ist und das ist der eine Teil
der Medaille und der andere Teil ist der
Entgrenzung des Krieges vorzubeugen
durch eine kluge Politik und
das muss man sich jeden Tag neu
erarbeiten und das tut die
Bundesregierung das tut der
Bundeskanzler und deswegen bedauere ich
das vor dem Hintergrund aktuelle
Ereignisse des Raketen Einschlags in
Polen manche überheilt manche auch finde
ich zu gefährlich und risikofvoll
reagiert haben nämlich dieser
Entgrenzung des Krieges müssen wir
vorbeugen und dazu gehört auch der einen
Seite die Ukraine zu unterstützen aber
auf der anderen Seite auch eine kluge
Diplomatie so wie es der Bundeskanzler
gemacht hat zu unternehmen Reise
Diplomatie aber insbesondere eben die
Länder mitzunehmen die nicht unmittelbar
am Anfang dieses Krieges auch auf der
Seite derjenigen gestanden haben der 141
Staaten sondern die sich der Stimme
enthalten haben aber trotzdem gegen den
Krieg sind und die muss man mitnehmen
und deswegen war es richtig diese Länder
zum G7 Gipfel einzuladen in diese Länder
zu reisen man muss mit wir sprechen die
mit einem nicht dergleichen Meinung von
Anfang an sind deswegen ist Diplomatie
kein Relikt vergangener Tage sondern
aktueller denn je deswegen auf der einen
Seite eine kluge Außenpolitik auf der
anderen Seite eine kluge Sozialpolitik
die sich den inneren Herausforderungen
stellt und ich bin froh dass unsere
Fraktion meine Fraktion in Dresden drei
notwendige Bedingungen formuliert hat
die auch sozusagen den Pfad
vorgezeichnet haben für diesen Weg auf
der einen Seite
unmittelbare soziale direkte Hilfen auf
der anderen Seite eine Grundsicherung an
bezahlbarer Energiesicherheit und
Zuversicht für die Verbraucher aber da
hängt ja doch mehr mit dazu wir wollen
den
industriellen Kern auch mit dieser
Grundsicherung in Deutschland erhalten
wir wollen uns dem was die USA zur Zeit
versucht auch zu wappnen mit einer
günstigen Energie aber gleichzeitig sage
ich dann auch Voraussetzung ist mit
dieser Frage der Grundsicherung an
Energie muss auch Standortsicherung in
Deutschland garantiert werden und
letztlich Beschäftigungssicherung weil
wir die Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer in dieser Arbeit halten
wollen und deswegen war es gut dass die
Bundesregierung zusammen mit den sie
tragenden Parteien auch die konzertierte
Aktion auf den Weg gebracht hat
Anknüpfen an die guten Erfahrungen
vergangener Jahrzehnte auch eben hier
Unterstützung gegeben hat die
Tarifvertragsparteien an ihre Pflichten
erinnert hat gute Arbeit mit gut
bezahltem Einkommen zu unterlegen aber
auf der anderen Seite auch
Abgabenfreiheit Steuerfreiheit mit
anzubieten und alle Verantwortlichen
Tarifvertragsparteien haben in den
vergangenen Wochen zu diesem Mittel
gegriffen und das schafft Solidarität
auf der einen Seite aber auch zuver für
die Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
meine Damen und Herren deswegen war die
konzertierte Aktion eine wichtige
Bedingung und gerade auch für uns
Sozialdemokratie und Sozialdemokraten
die so eng mit den Gewerkschaften
zusammenarbeiten war das ein gutes
Signal meine Damen und Herren und die
zweite Bedingung die wir damals auf
unserer Klausur im September in Dresden
formuliert haben ist die Menschen dürfen
nicht von Almosen abhängen sie brauchen
soziale Rechte in dieser Gesellschaft
deswegen der Mindestlohn aber auch die
Ausweitung der wohngeld-empfänger aber
was noch wichtiger ist in den letzten
Wochen was wir gemeinsam geschaffen
haben ist die Erhöhung des Kindergeldes
auf 250 € jedes Kind ist gleich viel
wert meine Damen und Herren und genau
das ist die Basis für eine
Kindergrundsicherung wovon ich jetzt
auch die Bundesregierung bitte diese
Kinder Grundsicherung anzupacken und sie
noch in dieser Legislatur wurde zu
verwirklichen wir haben die Basis meine
Damen und Herren durch die Erhöhung des
Kindergeldes gelegt zum anderen das
Bürgergeld ein gutes Ergebnis ich lass
mal einfach zur Seite wer sich wo
irgendwo durchgesetzt hat in paar Wochen
interessiert dass die Menschen überhaupt
nicht mehr wichtig ist
Qualifizierung und Weiterbildung der
Wert der Arbeit auch über diese
Grundsicherung über dieses Bürgergeld zu
erhalten aber was es noch ist es ist ein
Basisschutz für die Demokratie in einem
sozialen bundesstand das was uns die
Väter und die Mütter des Grundgesetzes
auferlegt haben ist dass das Bürgergeld
eine Rückversicherung dafür ist und die
dritte Bedingung
systemische Eingriffe dort wo der
sogenannte Markt der da alles richtet
eben auch aufgehalten und korrigiert
wird und auch das Verlangen wir in den
nächsten Tagen wenn die Vorlagen da sind
dass sie uns das genau anschauen ob das
eben auch erreichen meine Damen und
Herren ich habe von extrem und
anstrengenden Zeiten gesprochen sie sind
nicht mehr so wie in den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten wir müssen uns das endlich
vor Augen führen leider
repräsentieren Diktaturen autoritäre
Regierung mittlerweile 70 Prozent der
Weltbevölkerung liberale Demokratien
sind auf dem niedrigsten Stand angelangt
deswegen war es für mich auch bitter zu
erfahren dass es in der Europäischen
Union wie zum Beispiel im gründungsland
Italien mittlerweile Parteien an der
Spitze sind die diesem Extremismus eben
auch das Feld bereiten aber ich sage
auch gleichzeitig ohne Hoffnung können
wir die Demokratie nicht verteidigen
deswegen sind die Lichtblicke der
Wahlausgang in Brasilien meine Damen und
Herren die mitturms in den USA die
deutlich Ernüchterung über den brexit in
Großbritannien ja es ist anstrengend wir
müssen dem mit Ernsthaftigkeit und
Sachlichkeit entgegenstehen
aber ich bin überzeugt dass Demokratien
die Probleme am besten lösen können das
können wir gemeinsam beweisen meine
Damen und Herren vielen Dank
oh wolfenmütze nicht weil das der
Vorsitzende der SPD-Fraktion mit einem
Schwerpunkt Außenpolitik und Diplomatie
das ist ja seit längerer Zeit schon sein
Spezialgebiet ist auch im
außenpolitischer Sprecher gewesen der
SPD-Fraktion und wir sind aber
nichtsdestotrotz immer noch in der
Generaldebatte zum
des Bundeshaushalt 2023 und da ist der
nächste Redner Kino aus der afd-fraktion
12 Monate Bundesregierung wie sieht
eigentlich aktuell unser Land aus die
Inflation treibt Deutschland seine
Bürger und die heimische Wirtschaft
immer mehr um die Spirale dreht sich
immer weiter und schneller Entwertung
des Geldes sinkt eine Kaufkraft
rückläufiger absatzumsatz Menschen
halten das Geld zusammen ist ganz
verständlich geringere
investitionsleistungen von Unternehmen
sind die Folge und im Gegenzug die
steigende staatliche Transfer und
Unterstützungsleistungen gleichzeitig
fehlen mehr und mehr Arbeitskräfte die
überhaupt noch zur Wertschöpfung
beitragen können und sie gehen wieder
auf das übliche Patentrezept zurück
weitere Migration mittlerweile
Höchststände die das Jahr 2015 schon
übersteigen welche Erfolge für den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland haben
sie damit eigentlich erreicht in welchem
Verhältnis stehen diese Investitionen
und der volkswirtschaftlich
erwirtschaftete gewinnen überhaupt noch
und nein ich spreche nicht von
Kriegsflüchtlingen die hier um ich
spreche von denen die nicht in dieses
System integrierbar sind von
Transferleistungen leben müssen aber
gewalttätig in unserem Land auftreten
die können und wollen wir uns nicht
länger leisten meine Damen und Herren
und deshalb nutzen Sie nutzen sie
endlich die rechtlichen Möglichkeiten
voll aus die Dublin-Abkommen genauso
über die redeten mittlerweile überhaupt
niemand mehr wie die Rückführung in die
Heimatländer das gehört auch zur
Wahrheit dazu diese Regierungspolitik
bringt unser Land immer weiter in
Ungleichgewicht und die Verantwortlichen
Bundesminister steuerbern von Woche zu
Woche ohne eine langfristige Vision zu
haben die investieren nicht in unser
Land in unsere kritische Infrastruktur
sondern in die Werte geleitet der
Außenpolitik das ist ihr Schlagwort mit
den Sanktionen geplanten Schaden Sie uns
unseren Bürgern und unserer Wirtschaft
in Deutschland und das wird jeden Tag
offensichtlicher weder Russland noch
China sind auf uns überhaupt angewiesen
neue Märkte haben diese Länder seit
Jahren bereits erschlossen nur wir
leisten uns kein Teil mehr davon sein zu
wollen und das ist purer Übermut wir
haben
wir haben weder Gas noch Öl vorkommen
und investieren seit Jahrzehnten in
nicht grundlassfähige Energieträger wir
brauchen aber eine stabile und
zuverlässige Energieversorgung deshalb
muss auch nordstream als ein Teil davon
repariert im Betrieb genommen und auch
gesichert werden wir haben es heute
schon gehört der Bundeskanzler hat
übrigens da auch Aufklärung versprochen
es wird totgeschwiegen es kommt dazu
nichts sagen Sie es doch wer von unseren
Freunden dafür Verantwortung trägt sie
machen es nicht es ist einfach eine
Schande deswegen wir brauchen in unserem
Land Stabilität und Zuversicht weshalb
sollte eigentlich ein Unternehmen sich
überhaupt noch in Deutschland ansiedeln
überhaupt noch diesen Standort hier
wählen das verraten sie nicht nehmen wir
das Beispiel der BASF die Bürger an den
alten Bundesländern werden wohl genau
das gleiche Schicksal alleine wie die
Bürger der neuen Bundesländer nach 1990
führen werden abwandern Regionen werden
die industrialisiert Arbeitsplätze
verschwinden und junge Menschen ziehen
weg genau das scheint wahrscheinlich das
Ziel anderen Wirtschaftsminister Habig
zu sein ihre Politik der
Symptombekämpfung beseitigt die Ursachen
der Misere eben genau nicht wer sich als
Bundeswirtschaftsminister leichtsinnig
in einen Wirtschaftskrieg begibt hat
einfach nur versagt dieser
Wirtschaftsminister ist der schlechteste
der Bundesrepublik er ist wirklich eine
Schande für dieses Land
und unsere Nachbarn zeigen wie es anders
funktioniert bezahlbare
Energieversorgung oder auch eine
geringere Steuerlast überall in Europa
vor allem richten die Verantwortlichen
Regierung ihr Handeln eben auf die
Bereitstellung von Strukturen aus das
ist der Auftrag der Politik und nicht
Ideologie getriebene und starsinnige
Projekte auf Kosten des Bundeshaushalts
und damit auch der Steuerzahler es
braucht endlich wieder den Willen für
unser eigenes Land für unsere Bürger
eine vernünftige und verlässliche
Politik zu machen und das vermissen wir
bei Ihnen Herr Bundeskanzler und ihre
andere Regierung von Anbeginn sie sorgen
dafür dass die Idee Industrialisierung
Deutschlands immer weiter vorangetrieben
wird dass sich der Wohlstand und die
Vermögen dezimieren weite Teile der
Bürger leben mittlerweile nur noch von
der Substanz ihre Lösung die Steuern
Mikro-Bereich nach und feiern die
sogenannten entlastungspakete
200 Euro für Studenten 300 Euro für
Rentner bei einer Inflation die
mittlerweile weit über zehn Prozent ist
das ist am Ende was ankommt im Vergleich
zur Inflation sind es nur Allmosen die
Sie auszahlen aber die staatlichen
Zuschüsse dürfen nicht immer weiter
ansteigen das gefährdet unseren
Sozialstaat in Gänze erklären Sie den
Bürgern bitte auch dass die Schulden
gemeinsame Schulden sind gleiches gilt
für die sogenannten Sondervermögen es
war doch absehbar dass sie genau an
diesen Instrument Gefallen gefunden
haben dass diese dieses Instrument
ausnutzen damit sie den Bundeshaushalt
weiter umgehen können sondern Vermögen
sind Schulden die wir alle bezahlen
müssen alle Bürger an diesem Land
und ich bleibe dabei was ich auch schon
vor der letzten Bundestagswahl gesagt
habe das ist hier eben ein Kassensturz
geben muss den der Finanzminister
durchführen muss genau das ist Ziel wir
haben es ja erlebt wie der
personalaufwuchs gerade dieser
Bundesregierung jetzt vonstatten
gegangen ist 1700 neue Stellen aufwuchs
in den Ministerien in diesen Zeiten den
Menschen predigen sie sie wollen für die
Ukraine frieren und selbst vergrößern
sie noch einmal den Wasserkopf und die
mangelverwalter die die Bürger alle
durchfüttern müssen in diesen
wirtschaftlichen Zeiten ist das einfach
nur unerhört und auch unverschämt
und dann komme ich noch zur Studie des
ifo-Instituts denn die zeichnet genau
dieses düstere Bild bei den
Grundfertigkeiten wie Lesen Schreiben
und Rechnen fallen wir mittlerweile im
internationalen Vergleich auf Platz 30
diese und die Vorgängerregierung
beklagen seit Jahren den Mangel an
Fachkräften wir haben heute wieder
gehört und wie man es lösen möchte
gleichzeitig begrenzen Sie alles auf das
Mittelmaß und da muss man sich nur noch
die bundesbildungsbericht mal anschauen
was der besagt
52.000 junge Menschen sind im Jahr 2021
ohne Schulabschluss von der Schule
gegangen in der altersvorhorte der 20
bis 34-Jährigen sind mittlerweile 2,2
Millionen junge Menschen ohne Berufs-
und Studienabschlüsse ein Großteil sitzt
ja hier
[Applaus]
1,2 Millionen von diesen sind
beschäftigt erwerbstätig aber nur im
Niedriglohnsektor genau eine Million
geht genau in Hartz IV bzw zukünftigen
ihr Bürgergeld und werden dort auch
bleiben das ist das Ergebnis was sie als
Bundesregierung und der letzten im
übrigen
die Verantwortung für unsere Jugend
aufgegeben und wollen es nur durch
Zuwanderung lösen das ist der fatale
Fehler und dafür sind sie verantwortlich
und im Ergebnis haben wir neue
Generationen die genauso weit denken und
handeln können wie es die Ideologien der
Bundesregierung zulassen mittlerweile
geschaffen das wollen sie wahrscheinlich
sie werden die Bundesregierung sind die
Ware Fortschritts und Entwicklungsbremse
für dieses Land für Deutschland und
damit für den gesamten Kontinent Europa
und welche eigene nicht trennt
bestimmten ideale sie haben sieht man ja
ein Bundeskanzler der bei der
auslandsbesuche nicht in seiner
Muttersprache spricht oder eine
Außenministerin die glaubt mit Freunden
zu sprechen wenn sie auf polnisch
twittert daran sieht man welche ideale
sie haben das sind Ausverkauf von
unseren Interessen denn unsere
Interessen stehen für alle Staaten im
Vordergrund das sollte eigentlich die
Prämisse sein nur nicht für diese
Bundesregierung ihre Politik des Freund
feinschema ist aus einer anderen Zeit
sie brechen Brücken ab und sie schlagen
Türen zu die Generation vor ihnen für
uns aufgebaut und offen gehalten haben
das war das Erfolgsrezept im Übrigen
eine erfolgreichen Wirtschaftsnation die
machen es bin von Monaten und Jahren
dazu Nichte wir verfügen heute
über Kern und Kohlekraftwerke aber aus
Klima ideologischen Gründen begeben wir
uns lieber wieder in eine einseitige
Abhängigkeit eine Unglaubwürdigkeit
folgt der nächsten und sie sind dabei
vollkommen ungehemmt einerseits dürfen
wir kein russisches Gas mehr beziehen
auch aus Gründen der einseitigen
Abhängigkeit andererseits begeben wir
uns in die Hände der sogenannten Freunde
die seit Jahrzehnten rund um den Globus
ihre wirtschaftskriege führen wo ist
hier ihre Moralen wo sind hier ihre
Werte
transatlantischen Projekts eine halbe
Minute habe ich steigen sie von ihren
Elfenbeinturm herab und machen Sie
Politik für Deutschland für unser Land
zuerst
gegen sie vielen Dank
Thilo krupala ist
Fraktionsvorsitzender der AFD wird jetzt
noch mal ermahnt
iger
es steht ihnen nicht zu die amtierende
Präsidentin hier in dieser Weise zu
kritisieren wenn es dort etwas zu regeln
gibt
bringt als ihre parlamentarische
Geschäftsführung ganz sicher morgen im
Ältestenrat vor und jetzt für alle weil
wir sind in einer haushaltswoche da
gelten andere Regeln wenn es um die
Anrechnung der Redezeit geht da ist es
nämlich so dass ich sie zwar darauf
aufmerksam machen kann dass sie weiter
reden können das habe ich gerade getan
auch im Interesse ihre anderen
Fraktionskollegen weil ich die Redezeit
die sie überziehen jetzt den nächsten
Rednern abziehe und das kann ja im Alter
einfach das Gefechts mal passieren so
wie ich eben auch die Redezeit die
verbliebene Rest Redezeit der SPD
Fraktion korrigiert haben nachdem der
Kollege Mütze nicht zwei Minuten
überzogen hat
also ich diskutiere ich diskutiere dass
ihr überhaupt nicht mit ihrer Fraktion
und der nächste
so ich Herr Brandner ich diskutiere das
nicht mit ihnen sondern
wir Verfahren so ich werde diese
Dienstleistung in der weiteren
sitzungsführung für ihre Fraktion nicht
mehr vollziehen sondern wenn der Redner
die gesamtretezeit der Fraktion ausnutzt
dann gibt es eben keinen weiteren Redner
der AFD so einfach ist das
[Applaus]
so der nächste jetzt haben wir noch was
gelernt über parlamentarische
Gepflogenheiten auch was die Redezeiten
in einer haushaltswoche angeht so ganz
fremd ist das Prozedere eigentlich nicht
Andreas ist bereits am Pult ist der
nächste Redner einer der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
der Damen und Herren
Herr kropalla die Propaganda Moskaus
immer wieder hier im Bundestag anhören
zu müssen ist immer wieder unerträglich
aber ihnen laufen ja mittlerweile schon
die eigenen Abgeordneten weg damit zeigt
glaube ich dass der deutlich dass auch
in ihrer Fraktion ist einige gibt den
auffällt dass sie nichts anderes tun als
hier die Propaganda Moskau zu verbreiten
das was wir tun ist in der gleichen Zeit
und um die Menschen zu kümmern und
zweitens das Land zu modernisieren wir
kümmern uns auch um die Kulturbranche in
diesem Land die hat einen sehr sehr
schwierigen stand und das ist nicht nur
dieser Krise geschuldet das hat in
corona-zeiten begonnen wenn in der
corona-zeit viele Menschen nicht mehr
ins Theater gegangen sind wenn viele
Menschen nicht mehr in Lesungen gegangen
sind dann ist das etwas was ich bis
heute noch nicht wieder normalisiert hat
und dann fällt ist den theaternen
Kultureinrichtungen schwer jetzt
steigende Energiepreise auf Tickets
umzulegen und genau deswegen ist es so
wichtig auch für die Kulturbranche das
Robert Habeck Landkreis Bremse auf den
Weg bringt das Robert Habeck die
strompreisbremse auf den Weg bringt aber
wir begnügen uns nicht damit wir nehmen
ganz gezielt auch die Kulturbranche noch
mal in den Blick und haben dafür eine
Milliarde Euro ganz gezielt extra im
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds zur
Verfügung gestellt eines muss klar sein
wir sehen die Kulturbranche und wir
haben genau diese Branche jetzt im Blick
wir haben nicht nur die Institutionen im
Blick wir haben auch die Menschen in
dieser Krise im Blick und haben schon 22
im Jahr 22 die Künstlersozialkasse so
stabilisiert dass jetzt die Beiträge
nicht durch die Decke gehen und was wir
auch machen und deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir uns anschauen was heute
Abend im Vermittlungsausschuss passiert
wir stärken freischaffende wir stärken
selbstständige durch das Bürgergeld und
auch deswegen ist es so wichtig dass das
heute abend im Vermittlungsausschuss
verabschiedet wird schauen wir auf die
Karenzzeit was machen wir mit mit der
Karenzzeit die Karenzzeit gibt
Sicherheit gerade freischaffenden gerade
Kulturschaffenden das wenn sie in eine
Notsituation kommen dass sie dann nicht
als allererstes die Wohnung aufgeben
müssen sondern dass sie sich darauf
konzentrieren können dass es weitergeht
und genau diese Leute haben häufig einen
Plan wie es weitergeben kann dass Sie
nicht Ihr kleinstes Erspartes direkt
abgeben müssen wenn sie ins Bürgergeld
kommen dass sie nicht die Altersvorsorge
für die sie Monate lang gespart haben
jahrelang gearbeitet haben dass die
sofort weg ist wenn sie ins Bürgergeld
kommt all das hilft selbstständigen all
das hilft freischaffenden und deswegen
ist das Bürgergeld auch mehr Sicherheit
für Kultur schaffende
es geht uns um akute Hilfe es geht uns
aber auch darum Kunst und Kultur
langfristig in Deutschland wachsen zu
lassen und zu stärken und genau das
macht Claudia rot jetzt mit einem ganz
großartigen Projekt wir werden den
Kulturpass auf den Weg bringen und haben
dafür 100 Millionen Euro in diesem
Haushalt zur Verfügung gestellt wenn
Jugendliche 18 Jahre alt werden dann
soll jede und jeder 200 € bekommen um
damit Kultur vor Ort zu erleben das ist
für Jugendliche so wichtig die gerade in
der coronazeit kein Leid Konzert erleben
konnten die gerade in der coronazeit
keine Lesungen in der Kneipe erleben
konnten so viel nicht erleben konnten
und nach dieser coronazeit bei
Jugendlichen die Lust an Kultur zu
wecken ihnen Zugänge dazu zu geben die
Vielfalt der kulturellen Landschaft vor
Ort zu erleben all das machen wir jetzt
und schaffen mit dem kulturpassen sein
großartiger Fortschritt den die
kulturstaatsministerin hier in
Deutschland auf den Weg bringen wird in
Frankreich gibt's das seit langem jetzt
zurück Claudia das nach Deutschland sein
großer Schritt für die Kulturbranche
hier im Land
der Haushalt
ist der erste den die ampelregierung
ohne und auch das Parlament hier ohne
Vorarbeit der alten großen Koalition auf
den Weg gebracht hat und jetzt sieht man
immer deutliche den Kurswechsel den wir
machen wir haben uns auf den Weg gemacht
Klimapolitik endlich konsequent zum Teil
von Kulturpolitik zu machen ich möchte
dass seinem Beispiel deutlich machen was
beim museum des 20 Jahrhunderts am
Berliner Kulturforum geplant wurde hat
klimapolitisch nichts mit einem
Kulturbau des 21 jahrhunderts zu tun so
wie das Museum ursprünglich gedacht war
ist es ein einziger klima-albraum zum
Vergleich es würde ca viermal so viel
Energie verbrauchen wie das Alte Museum
hier in Berlin nur dass das Alte Museum
200 Jahre alt ist und daran sieht man
eins das ist ein Beispiel für eine ganz
spezielle Haltung die wir in den letzten
Jahren Jahrzehnten den haben wir haben
als Gesellschaft so geplant so gebaut so
gelebt als wären wir die Könige der Welt
so geplant und gebaut als gäbe es
unbegrenzt billige Energie als gäbe es
die Klimakrise nicht als gäbe es keinen
Morgen mehr damit muss Schluss sein das
kann so nicht weitergehen deswegen
werden wir umplanen und deswegen stellen
wir eben Etat 10 Millionen genau dafür
zur Verfügung wir werden neu planen neu
bauen und das Nötigste angeziel ist es
ein Kulturbau zu haben der mit seinem
Energiehunger nicht mehr dazu beiträgt
dass wir die Lebensgrundlagen die auf
den auf die wir angewiesen sind
zerstören und damit geht eins einher das
muss eine Wegmarke sein dafür dass wir
in Zukunft nicht mehr so bleiben nicht
mehr so bauen dürfen sondern
klimapolitisch den nächsten Schritt in
der Kulturpolitik gehen
nicht zuletzt Kulturpolitik ist immer
auch demokratiepolitik wenn Menschen
sich abends zum Singen treffen wenn
Menschen im Chor zusammenkommen dann
gibt es ein Gefühl ein Gefühl gemeinsam
etwas zu schaffen und deswegen haben wir
zwei neue Fonds auf den Weg gebracht zum
einen einen vor für amateurmusik fünf
Millionen stellen wir dafür zur
Verfügung und zum anderen ein
festival-förderfonds ebenfalls 5
Millionen Euro wenn Menschen gemeinsam
Kultur erleben wenn Menschen gemeinsam
etwas unternehmen dann sind das nicht
die Menschen die am Ende denen
hinterherlaufen die Hass verbreiten und
Menschen gegeneinander Aufwickeln
insofern dieser Etat ist ein krisenetats
ein klimapolitischer Etat und ist auch
ein Etat für mehr Demokratie in
Deutschland
Andreas audresch stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen in der der Generaldebatte des
Bundestags in dem es auch viel über und
um Energie Energie Sicherheit und
Energieversorgung geht und wenn sie
gelegentlich sehen dass sie Abgeordnete
und oder sogar Ministerinnen hier etwas
besser eingepackt sind als sie das
gewohnt sind dann liegt das daran dass
auch hier im Bundestag die Temperatur
runter geregelt wurde hintergrund ist
die Energieversorgung
Sicherungsmaßnahmen Verordnung 19 Grad
gelten jetzt hier im Plenarsaal des
Deutschen Bundestages also auch recht
frisch Otto Fricke ist am Pool der
haushaltspolitische Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion
Haushalt und das muss man das muss man
und ich versuche es vermitteln zu sagen
ist ein Haushalt des Übergangs wir
kommen aus einer Zeit in der uns mit
Corona und den Folgen unzugleich mit dem
was Russland Angriffskrieg gegen Bio
keine führt viele Probleme auf einmal in
unseren Haushalt hineingekommen sind
Corona gleitet hoffentlich aus kostet
aber noch und die Auswirkungen dessen
was Russland macht erleben wir noch an
vielen Ecken und Enden und dennoch ist
es uns gelungen und viele werden jetzt
sagen ja das ist euch so wichtig ja das
ist wichtig und dennoch ist es uns
gelungen im Kernhaushalt die
Schuldenbremse einzuhalten und
gleichzeitig für die notwendigen Dinge
die wir sowohl im Bereich Verteidigung
als auch in der Frage Elektrizität Wärme
haben in Sondervermögen Sicherheit zu
geben und das sage ich an auch deutlich
meine Richtung cdu/cs
euer reden sei ja ja nein nein aber
nicht immer dieses Mischmasch vor ein
paar Monaten hieß es noch diese
Koalition ist nicht in der Lage die
notwendigen Mittel zur Verfügung zu
stellen dann stellen wir mit den 200
Milliarden die Mittel zur Verfügung was
sagt die zu ja aber wir wissen ja noch
gar nicht genau wofür jetzt kommen wir
mit dem Vorschlägen genau wofür und
jetzt sagt sie nur wer das passt uns
eigentlich gar nicht das ist keine
Oppositionspolitik das ist
obstruktionspolitik und mehr ist es an
der Stelle nicht und zum Thema ob die
Schuldenbremse wirkt oder nicht alle die
cdu/csu sagt nicht DIE LINKE sagt doch
die wirkt das ist ja ganz schlimm wir
können immer noch nicht mehr ausgeben
und ich will es als Haushälter mal
vorsichtig mit Blick auf die
Regierungsbank so formulieren hätte es
die Schuldenbremse nicht in diesem
Haushalt gegeben wäre ich mir sicher
hätte es noch ganz viele Wünsche gegeben
die noch in diesem Haus sind
hineingekommen sind insofern sorgt die
Schuldenbremse an der Stelle dafür dass
wir da wo es notwendig ist durch
verstärkte Mittel sichern aber
gleichzeitig im nächsten Jahr auch sagen
wohin die Reise mit dieser Koalition
geht nämlich in Richtung Stabilität bei
gleichzeitig ausreichender Versorgung in
all den Bereichen wo wir es in einer
sozialen Marktwirtschaft machen müssen
und Herr Kollege dobend da ist auch
nichts in dem Schattenhaushalt woher hat
denn die cdu/csu die ganzen Zahlen naja
ich hoffe jedenfalls deshalb weil sie
einfach mal den Haushalt gucken muss
alles das das Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr die 200 werden alles da steht
da drin da ist nichts im Schatten es sei
denn man ist nicht in der Lage bei Licht
im Haushalt ein wenig nachzulesen so und
dann komme ich und dann komme ich noch
zu einer Sache mit ihren angeblich 500
Milliarden das will ich dann auch mal
sagen ich habe ja erst gedacht ich mache
ein Milchmädchen Vergleich der ist aber
erstens falsch zweitens passt er nicht
drittens wäre es eine Beleidigung mit
Adam Riese das klappt aber auch nicht
denn der ist ja selbst aus Bayern nach
Thüringen ausgewandert also geht das
auch nicht meine Damen und Herren wenn
sie sagen es sind 500 Milliarden neue
Schulden dann haben sie immer noch nicht
den verstanden was der Unterschied
zwischen einer schönen Ermächtigung ist
um im Notfall ausreichend zu haben und
was was tatsächliche Schulen sind aber
gehen wir mal in die Mathematik des
Kollegen Dobrindt und des Kollegen Merz
dann ist die Rekordverschuldung in dem
Jahr gekommen als wir 600 Milliarden im
Rahmen von corona-hilfen für WSF zur
Verfügung gestellt haben Herr Kollege
Dobrindt wenn sie schon solche komischen
Rechnungen machen weil sie an
oppositionsdiskalkulie leiden dann
sollten Sie sie auch wenigstens ehrlich
machen so und dann komme ich noch zu der
Frage und das will ich dann hier auch
noch abräumen zu der berühmten Kiste mit
den Immobilien und der Frage warum das
in der Erbschaftsteuer hochgeht wer hat
uns den Mist denn eingebrockt ein
gewisser Herr Seehofer der die
immobilienverordnung gegen
immobilienwertverordnung erhöht hat der
wahres dessen Mist müssen wir jetzt
wegräumen das ist der Grund und dann zu
tun als wäre es diese Regierung das ist
finde ich schon schlimm und dann will
ich zum Schluss doch noch mal bei der
Frage wie sich verhalten etwas sagen und
ich empfehle das allen weil man immer
denkt auch das ist so old style das ist
so nämlich da liegen draußen doch immer
noch die Änderungsanträge da sagt die
CDU CSU sparen sparen sparen ihr macht
das schlecht und dann geht man draußen
rum und guckt einfach noch mal ich nehme
mir mal die Anträge dann wieder da
liegen und das sind nur die die bis
heute Mittag da sind die Änderungsantrag
der cdu/csu 18 Millionen nicht einsparen
mehr ausgeben Antrag der cdu/csu 150
Millionen nicht einsparen mehr ausgeben
andere Ziele CSU 40 Millionen nicht
einsparen mehr ausgeben Anteil der cocsu
188 Millionen noch mal 20 Millionen
nicht einsparen mehr ausgeben mir fällt
dazu nur König Claudius ein erster Akt
zweite Szene mit einem heiteren und
einem nassen Auge um es deutlich zu
sagen heiter wenn ich sehe dass die
Mathematik einfach nicht beherrschen und
im Nassen Auge dass wir eine so
schlechte Opposition haben aber so ist
es dann wohl wir werden auf jeden Fall
gucken müssen
dafür verwende ich die letzte Minute vor
Präsidentin wir müssen jetzt gucken was
im nächsten Jahr notwendig ist und dass
der einzige Punkt wo ich dem Kollegen
März zustimmen kann es wird um ein
Wettrennen in dieser sich verändernden
Welt gehen wo und wie investiert wird
und das sage ich ausdrücklich wo und wie
in Nachhaltigkeit in Demografie in
Digitalisierung investiert wird wenn wir
das nicht schaffen hier an der Stelle
der Ort der Ort auch in Demokratie kann
man investieren und zwar dadurch dass
man Arbeitsplätze schaffen weil das das
essenziellste überhaupt ist dafür dass
unsere Sozialsysteme funktionieren aber
ich will das deutlich sagen die Aufgabe
für uns alle auch mit schlechter
Rechenfähigkeit wird sein wie wir dafür
sorgen dass wir der Welt sagen hier
lohnt es sich zu investieren hier
entsteht die Zukunft hier entsteht
Nachhaltigkeit hier findet
Digitalisierung statt weil wir
verstanden haben was diese zeitenwände
bedeutet herzlichen Dank
Otto Fricke war das der
haushaltspolitische Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion und nach Alice im
Wunderland und Jim Knopf sind wir jetzt
auch bei Hamlet angekommen so gut wie
keine Rede von Otto Fricke im Deutschen
Bundestag ohne Shakespeare Zitat diesmal
hat der König Claudius wie gesagt aus
dem Hamlet bemüht hier geht es weiter
mit Kirsten Radomski aus der
Unionsfraktion
ich muss kurz auf den Kollegen Fricke
eingehen ja Herr Fricke sie haben ja
gerade hier mehrere Papiere hochgehoben
und uns vorgeworfen wir würden nur Geld
ausgeben ich weiß nicht was Ihr Anliegen
an der Stelle ist wenn Ihr Wunsch
tatsächlich ist dass wir die über 200
Anträge die wir im Haushalts ausgeschuss
gestellt haben dann auch noch mal als
Änderungsanträge ins Plenum einbringen
dann verlagern wir sicherlich die Arbeit
die wir in den Ausschüssen machen in den
Plenarsaal und da das ja auch alles
Papier ist wie sie gerade richtig
festgehalten haben halte ich das nicht
für sinnvoll wir haben die Punkte
gesetzt als Fraktion wo wir sagen das
sind wichtige Punkte an denen hätten wir
etwas anders gemacht das müssen Sie
nicht teilen
zum zweiten Mal beraten wir jetzt über
den Einzelplan des Bundeskanzlers und
von vielen darin enthaltenen
Themenfeldern von Ostdeutschland bis zur
Integration möchte ich zu Beginn auf die
Kultur eingehen Frau Roth in aktuellen
Zeit bewegten Zeiten sind die deutlichen
Erhöhungen im Etat der
kulturstaatsministerin aus meiner Sicht
ein wichtiges Zeichen deshalb liebe
Koalitionsfraktionen betrachten Sie es
jetzt mal als positives Signal von uns
dass wir im Rahmen des
Haushaltsverfahren einigen ihrer
Projekten auch zugestimmt haben hierbei
möchte ich auf die wichtige
Digitalisierung der Dokumentation von
ns-
an anderen Stellen Herr audritsch
konnten wir umso weniger zustimmen
gerade bei vermeintlich wohlklingenden
Projekten denn wir als Opposition
schauen ganz genau hin was sie da machen
etwa bei dem von Ihnen geplanten
Kulturpass der insbesondere jungen
Menschen den Zugang zur Kultur
ermöglichen soll verstehen Sie mich
jetzt hier an dieser Stelle bitte nicht
falsch grundsätzlich ist die Idee
Menschen oder junge Menschen für Kultur
zu begeistern ja gut aber wie bei allen
Dingen geht es natürlich und das ist die
entscheidende Frage um das wie
beim Wii halten wir es tatsächlich für
schwierig die 100 Millionen Euro
einzustellen wenn noch kein Plan
vorliegt und die Koalitionspartner im
Ausschuss offensichtlich
unterschiedlicher Ansicht über die
Ausgestaltung sind sie handeln hier nur
nach dem Motto wenn schon kein Plan dann
wenigstens Geld einstellen
dies ist ein Beispiel dafür dass die
Bundesregierung und die sie tragenden
Fraktionen leider konzeptlos sind an der
ein oder anderen Stelle was fehlt ist
ein echter Kompass statt Schlagworte wie
green culture mit denen einige wohl
meinen bestimmte Klientel zu befriedigen
statt ihren Kompass zu justieren begeben
Sie sich auf die Spielwiese der
Symbolpolitik Frau Staatsministerin das
Land und die Menschen haben derzeit viel
drängendere Probleme als eine Debatte
über die Kuppel des Berliner Schlosses
aus unserer Sicht wenden sie dem
christlichen Spruch und dessen
Überblendung zu viel Aufmerksamkeit zu
und dann auch wieder ohne konkrete
Kosten benennen zu können
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben ein
Recht darauf dass in angespannten Zeiten
der Fokus auf das wirklich notwendige
gerichtet wird doch die em-ampelmehrheit
hat unseren Maßgabe Beschluss gegen die
Verwendung von Haushaltsmitteln zu
diesem Zweck abgelehnt
an anderer Stelle dann wieder fehlt es
an Aufmerksamkeit und dementsprechend
weil wir über den Etat sprechen auch an
Geld
ich möchte einige schlaglichte aufwerfen
die wir als cdu/csu-fraktion für wichtig
befunden hätten den sie leider nicht
zugestimmt haben ein aufwuchs beim
Zukunftsprogramm Kino eine Erhöhung der
Mittel für das ostpreußische
Landesmuseum weitere Mittel für die
Deutsche Welle zugunsten ukrainisch und
russischsprachiger Angebote und 500.000
Euro für das geplante Mahnmal für die
Opfer kommunistischer Gewaltherrschaft
in Deutschland das sind nur einige
unsere Vorschläge Herr Fricke die wir im
Ausschuss gemacht haben für den
Kulturetat aber ich möchte am Ende
vielleicht auch noch auf das vielleicht
strittigste Thema in diesem Einzelplan
kommen
den geplanten Erweiterungsbau des
Bundeskanzleramts den der Bundeskanzler
und seine Behörde unbedingt in dieser
Größenordnung realisieren wollen
wir als Union haben uns gegen den Bau in
dieser Form und die Kostensteigerung
inklusive Risikokosten von 777 Millionen
ausgesprochen denn
seit der Planung hat sich viel verändert
wenn sie mir jetzt nicht zuhören und die
ganze Zeit schreien können sie ja meine
Argumentation gar nicht nachvollziehen
der 24 Februar diesen Jahres steht für
einen tiefen Einschnitt von der
Haushaltspolitik bis zur
gesamtwirtschaftlichen Lage nachdem wir
im September über die Mehrkosten
informiert worden haben wir gefordert
neue Einsparpotenziale zu treffen um die
Kosten zu dämpfen die Ampel hat
abgelehnt
in angespannten Zeiten mit besonderen
finanziellen Herausforderungen ich nehme
beispielhaft das Stichwort
Sondervermögen plädieren wir für eine
Verschiebung der Baumaßnahme wenn eine
Reduzierung der Kosten angeblich nicht
möglich ist
sehr geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler schön
dass sie wieder da sind ihr
Kanzleramtschef hat uns Hauseltern
mitgeteilt dass sie im Februar
entschieden haben dass dieser Bau gebaut
also dass die der Erweiterungsbau jetzt
umgesetzt werden soll ich gehe davon aus
dass das vor ihrer Rede vom
27.02.2022 war und es würde von
Vorbildfunktion und politischer Weisheit
Zeugen getroffene Entscheidungen
aufgrund der neuen Situation zu
überdenken und dem Wort Zeitenwende
Taten folgen zu lassen vielen Dank
Kerstin Radomski ist wirklich im
Haushaltsausschuss und in der
cdu/csu-fraktion und auch sie hat
geredet hier in der Debatte zum
Kanzleramt und Bundeskanzler die ja die
Generaldebatte ist in einer
haushaltswoche jetzt die SPD-Vorsitzende
Saskia esken
am Samstag jährte sich die
Bundestagswahl mit der Willy Brandt 1972
als Kanzler der Bundesrepublik bestätigt
wurde 50 Jahre ist das jetzt her viele
Zitate brennt aus dieser Zeit sind
legendär dazu gehört natürlich auch sein
Appell mehr Demokratie zu wagen denn das
ist sie unsere Demokratie sie ist ein
Wagnis
DemokratInnen und Demokraten gehen in
Wagnis an wenn Sie Politik offen und
partizipativ gestalten wenn sie
multipolare wenn sie lagerübergreifende
Koalitionen mit Demokraten eingehen denn
das bedeutet geteilte macht als wahre
Macht zu begreifen im Inneren wie im
äußeren die Demokratie ist also ein
Wagnis und gleichzeitig ist sie wie Rolf
Mütze nicht gerade ganz richtig gesagt
hat unsere einzige Hoffnung unser
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz zeigt eine
solche wagemutige hoffnungsfrohe
demokratische Gesinnung an jedem Tag und
mit großem Erfolg in der Führung der
Ampel ebenso wie auf den internationalen
Bühnen
und es ist kein Zufall dass der
Koalitionsvertrag den wir vor einem Jahr
geschlossen haben den Titel trägt mehr
Fortschritt Wagen als ich für die SPD
diesen Vertrag unterzeichnet habe da
waren wir zwei Dinge besonders wichtig
erstens wir formulieren den Anspruch
dieses Land zu modernisieren den
Wirtschaftsstandort und die Gesellschaft
fit zu machen für die Zukunft in
Anerkennung der Realität und inmitten
der Krisen die wir erleben und
bewältigen müssen mit aktiver
Industriepolitik mit einer sicheren und
bezahlbaren Energieversorgung und nicht
zuletzt mit einer Strategie zur
Bewältigung des Fachkräftemangels denn
das ist die Achillesferse unserer
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung
zweitens geht es mir geht es uns um
Respekt Respekt für jeden Menschen
Respekt für jeden Abschluss für jede
Tätigkeit und deshalb haben wir den
Mindestlohn auf 12 Euro erhöht wir
senken die Abgaben für geringe Einkommen
unter 2.000 Euro damit sich Leistung
lohnt und der modernisieren unseren
Sozialstaat das neue Bürgergeld bedeutet
zusammen mit der Ausweitung des
wohngelds und der wesentlichen Erhöhung
von Kindergeld und Kinderzuschlag die
größte sozialstaatsreform seit 20 Jahren
wir wollen eine Sozialstaat der Menschen
auf Augenhöhe begegnet und sie
bestmöglich und ganz individuell dabei
unterstützt ein selbstbestimmtes Leben
zu führen egal ob sie arbeiten doch der
Lohn ihrer Arbeit reicht nicht zum Leben
ob sie erwerbslos sind doch es fehlt
ihnen die Qualifikation ob sie in
Ausbildung sind oder ob sie eine Chance
im sozialen Arbeitsmarkt brauchen denn
so vielfältig sind die Lebenssituationen
von Menschen in Grundsicherung wir
werden ihnen gerecht und stärken ihre
Teilhabe am gesellschaftlichen Leben das
ist für mich Respekt
ganz klar haben wir mit der Reform des
Bürgergeldes im Blick das Erwerbslose
Menschen in Arbeit kommen aber
nachhaltig und nicht nur so dass sie in
einer ewigen Drehtür zwischen prekärer
Arbeit und Jobcenter gefangen sind und
deshalb stellen wir Qualifikationen
jetzt in den Vordergrund schaffen den
vermittlungsvorgang ab und schaffen ein
Ausbildungsbonus und ein
Weiterbildungsgeld im Kern bedeutet
dieses Bürgergeld also mehr Geld mehr
Teilhabe mehr Qualifikation und Meer
Respekt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen Respekt
für jedermann und jede Frau das
beinhaltet auch Respekt vor anderen
Meinungen und Perspektiven bevor sie zu
auf der rechten Seite des parlamentens
nein sie sind damit nicht gemeint es
gibt keine Toleranz und es gibt keinen
Respekt für die Intoleranz und ihr Hass
ist keine Meinung
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen in
Respekt und mit ehrlichen Interesse an
der Auffassung anderer haben wir diese
Koalition gebildet dass wir unsere
Vorhaben gemeinsam so voranbringen dass
niemand mit der Faust in der Tasche zur
Abstimmung gehen muss das ist eine
besondere Qualität der Arbeit in dieser
Koalition und dafür gilt man ganz
herzlicher Dank den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die in der Regierung und die im
parlamentarischen Verfahren immer wieder
und jeden Tag daran arbeiten dass das
gelingt und zwar sowohl in der
Bewältigung der multiplen Krisen als
auch in der Modernisierung unseres
Landes und in der Stärkung des
Zusammenhalts vielen Dank
[Applaus]
SPD-Vorsitzende in der Debatte in der
Generaldebatte in der haushaltswoche zum
Bundeshaushalt 2023 und da hören wir
jetzt Smart Team Erwin Renner aus der
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
des Präsidium sehr geehrte Damen sehr
geehrte Herren wir sprechen über den
Haushalt der Bundesbeauftragten für
Kultur und Medien diejenige die so gerne
die Inschrift an der Kuppel des Berliner
Stadtschlosses überblenden würde oder so
wie die Partei Genuss in Werbung das
historische Ratsfrau Kreuz in Münster
zum Treffen der G7 Außenminister
entfernen ließ ist ist das was unsere
deutsche Kultur und unser christliches
geprägte Nation tatsächlich blüht in der
Schutz unserer Kultur in die
Verantwortung von Grünen und Linken
kulturleugnen ein Heim gegeben wird die
weniger das Fremde so sehr lieben als
das eigene so sehr hassen dann wird hier
nicht für die Pflege und den Erhalt der
Kultur Sorge getragen und unsere Kultur
und unsere Identität wird
parteipolitisch umgedeutet umgeschrieben
und in einen ideologischen grünen linken
geisteskäfig eingepfercht
es ist noch niemals eine gute Idee
gewesen Geld in die Pflege eines Gartens
zu stecken indem man vorher den Bock zum
Gärtner gemacht hat was hier am Ende
übrig bleibt schmeckt bestenfalls den
Box selbst und auch seiner gefräßigen
Herde wir sehen doch überall eine sich
selbst festklebende ja die Kulturgüter
beschmutzt und auch Menschenleben
gefährdet die uns ihre linksideologische
Schmalspur wählt sich aufzwingen will
wir sehen dass Kultur und Buchpreise
zunehmend nur noch für schamlose und
peinliche Individuen vergeben werden ist
das wirklich Kunst oder kann das weg
nehmen wir die Deutsche Welle das mit
immer mehr Millionen Euro Steuergeld
verwöhnt wird hier wird potenziellen
zuwandern das deutsche Paradies nahe und
ans Herz gelegt hier wird das Tragen von
Kopftüchern auch hierzulande beworben
und die Deutsche Welle engagiert sich
zudem auch im Ausland für Revolutionen
Medienkunst und Kultur müssen
staatskritisch sein das ist ihre Aufgabe
und Berufung meine Damen und Herren doch
hier wird mit dem Geld gesteuerts alles
seit Jahrzehnten die Kumpanei mit der
Kultur
alimentiert die dem opportunistischen
Grundsatz holidicht best brotig ist das
Lied ich sing und ich sage Ihnen
Kumpanei ist Lumperei
ich schließe mit einem Zitat von
Friedrich Hölderlin doch wo Gefahr ist
wächst das Retten der auch und ganz
sicher ist die bolschewoge Kulturpolitik
der Ampel ist nicht das rettende sondern
sie ist das sie ist die treuende Gefahr
meine Damen und Herren danke
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
hat nun Stefan Gebhardt
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
haushaltsberater Beratungen lassen sich
immer sehr unterschiedlich lesen ich
möchte jetzt eine ostdeutsche
Perspektive hinzufügen ein Beispiel noch
immer sind im Osten Löhne und Gehälter
niedriger die Vermögen und
rücklinkanlagen sind kleiner ungefähr
halb so groß im Ergebnis ist die
finanzielle Belastbarkeit zwischen
Rostock und Chemnitz auch nach 32 Jahren
Einheit deutlich geringer das führt dann
in einer Krisensituation schnell Zuhörer
und Sicherheit und das wiederum zu
lautem und lauterem Unmut deswegen ist
es wichtig hier zu signalisieren die
Ampel handelt die energiepreisbremsen
kommen gut so das 49 Euro bundesticket
kommt gut so das Kindergeld wird erhöht
gut so
damit sind nicht alle Probleme gelöst
wann wären sie das je aber dieser
Haushalt gibt vielen Menschen halt das
Parlament hat gearbeitet der
angekündigte heiße Herbst der bleibt
doch recht kühl
jene die die Unsicherheit und den Unmut
gerade im Osten für ihre ganz eigene
Agenda instrumentalisieren ja
missbrauchen wollten schauen ziemlich in
die Röhre und auch da sage ich gut so
ein weiteres Signal mit dem Bürgergeld
kann ein ostdeutsches Trauma ein Stück
weit ein Stück weit abgestreift werden
das heißt keine Entwarnung aber machen
wir uns das noch mal bewusst nach den
krassen Umbrüchen der 90er Jahre mit
galoppierender Arbeitslosigkeit für die
Arbeitslosenhilfe ersatzlos weg
entflecht Entrichtung und öffentliche
Geringschätzung taten dann ihr Werk
viele Menschen und ihm
überdurchschnittlich viele Menschen im
Osten wurden dazu gebracht auch jedem
noch so unpassenden und mies bezahlten
Job anzunehmen diesen Zustand zu
verlassen das ist ein Schritt den
weitere folgen müssen
warum aber nun wurden weder 49 Euro
bundesticket noch energiepreisbremse
Bürgergeld oder Kindergeld warum wurde
all das bislang kaum unter dem Ost-West
Unterschieden betrachtet es vielen
Ostdeutsche reflexions- und
debattenräume um Interesse und
Bewusstsein zu verankern zu wecken sich
explizit als ostdeutsch bezeichnende
Medien vielen weiterhin zum Vergleich
Nordwest und Süddeutsche Medien bekennen
sich dazu schon in ihrem Namen
ostdeutsche überhaupt nicht das ist ein
gesellschaftlicher mit dem
transformationszentrum ist ein
reflexions- und debattenraum geplant mit
dem Campus der Demokratie ein weiterer
auf dem Weg ich kann da die
Bundesregierung nur ermutigen rasch und
konsequent diesen Weg zu gehen denn
Vertrauen in den Staat in die
Institutionen und die Menschen die diese
prägen das muss verdient werden dazu
braucht es einen funktionierenden und
handelnden Staat dazu braucht es
Identifikation dazu braucht es
Repräsentanz das macht sich fest an den
Institutionen vor Ort
das macht sich fest an der Sichtbarkeit
von Personen im und aus dem Osten und
damit eben auch in Schlüsselpositionen
Gesichter und Geschichten das braucht es
und finanzielle Widerstandsfähigkeit
unabhängig von den Himmelsrichtungen
durch das konsequente Angleichen der
einkommens- und Vermögensverhältnisse
das geht nicht mit einem Haushalt das
bedarf weiterer struktureller
Veränderung und eben dieses Bewusstsein
diese östliche Perspektive auch übrigens
über und die Grenzen unserer Republik
hinaus es ist zum Beispiel sehr stark
dass wir ein deutsch-französisches
Bahnticket für die Jugend hier auf dem
Weg bringen dem muss nun ein eben
solches deutsch-polnisches Ticket folgen
oder in Deutschland
das ist dann eben diese Perspektive
dieses Bewusstsein und das ist auch
2023 ein Arbeitsauftrag an alle von uns
vielen Dank
für die FDP-Fraktion hat nun der Kollege
Thomas Hacker das Wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Kultur
Deutschland ist eine Kulturnation fragt
man die Menschen auf der Straße was
Kultur für sie ausmacht wird man viele
Antworten erhalten graphic Nobels
nft-kunst in Bayreuth vielleicht Wagner
Opern Literatur und Musik von Klassik
bis Pop Plattdeutsch oder Ballett dazu
die breiten kulturellen Traditionen die
Menschen aus ihren Heimatländern mit
nach Deutschland gebracht haben Kultur
und ihre Ausdrucksformen sind so
vielfältig wie die Menschen die sie
erreichen deutlich ist ihr Beitrag
jedoch zu unserem gesellschaftlichen
Miteinander vielleicht mag man sogar von
einem Beitrag zur Zivilisation sprechen
auch wenn das das war ein strittig
diskutiert wird der Soziologe durch
Becker fasst es in einem esse zur
corona-krise meines Empfindens nach
Treffen zusammen ich zitiere
der wichtigste Beitrag der Kultur
besteht darin für eine Qualität der
Begegnung des Gesprächs der Debatte zu
sorgen die es erlaubt sich im besten
Sinne des Wortes zivilisiert zu
verständigen und darum geht es
und darum geht es uns in der Ampel in
diesen umwälzenden Zeiten angesichts der
großen gesellschaftlichen
bewährungs-krise ist im Kulturbetrieb
noch nicht ganz überwunden und morgen
sind es bereits neun Monate in denen der
völkerrechtswidrige Russlands gegen die
Ukraine in Europa tobt der
Bundeshaushalt
2023 setzt sein entschlossenes Zeichen
für Kultur und für Medien wo andere den
Rotstift ansetzen würden stellen wir
erneut mehr Geld bereit dafür danke ich
Christian Lindner und Claudia Roth und
den Haushältern ausdrücklich so können
wir die kulturpolitischen Schwerpunkte
unserer gemeinsamen Koalition fortsetzen
wir setzen aber gleichzeitig auch neue
Impulse der Kulturpass richtet sich
besonders an die junge Generation gerade
sie liebe Union waren es doch die in den
letzten zwei Jahren der Pandemie die
großen Leidtragenden waren die
Faszination von
live-kulturerlebnissen können durch
YouTube Netflix oder
nicht wirklich dauerhaft kompensiert
werden ja Kultur braucht Investitionen
Investitionen in Kulturdenkmäler wie die
Andreas Kapellen in Bamberger Dom oder
in Kulturorte final hier in Berlin mit
dem Haushalt kommen wir aber auch unsere
erinnerungskulturellen Verantwortung
nach in einer digitalen Welt muss die
Auseinandersetzung mit und die
Erinnerung an die NS-Verbrechen auch im
digitalen Raum stattfinden hier können
wir die junge Generation erreichen und
für die unvorstellbaren
zivilisationsbrüche in unserer
Geschichte sensibilisieren
unsere erinnerungskulturelle Verhandlung
gilt auch für die Jahrzehnte in einem
getrennten und schließlich
wiedervereinten Deutschland wir stärken
nicht allein die Arbeit von
Gedenkstätten und Institutionen sondern
auch die Bereitstellung eines digitalen
kollektiven Gedächtnisses mit 13,5
Milliarden kann das
Bundesarchiv auch in den nächsten Jahren
die vorhandenen Dokumente der
Staatssicherheit der DDR digitalisieren
und für die Nachwelt erhalten für uns
bleibt der aufrichtige Blick in die
Vergangenheit die Voraussetzung für die
demokratische Gestaltung unserer Zukunft
über den einen oder anderen Antrag den
wir heute auch beraten kann man nur den
Kopf schütteln es ist zwar richtig dass
man mal für die Opfer kommunistischer
Gewaltherrschaft in Deutschland zu
unterstützen wer dafür aber die Deutsche
Welle kürzen will hat die Zeichen der
Zeit nicht erkannt
die Deutsche Welle
die Deutsche Welle hat einen
entscheidenden Anteil daran unsere
gemeinsamen europäischen Werte unsere
Demokratie unsere Kultur unsere Freiheit
in die Welt hinauszutragen sie hilft
exil-journalisten und Journalisten
genauso ihre Arbeit fortzusetzen sich
dem russischen Diktator entgegenstellen
zu können liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Bundeshaushalt 23 schafft die
richtigen Voraussetzung die kulturelle
Vielfalt zu stärken die
Kulturschaffenden zu unterstützen
Menschen die vor dem Krieg fliehen
Hoffnung zu geben so kann die Kultur und
der letzte Satz Frau Präsident ihre
Wirkung entfalten ihren Beitrag leisten
für eine freie und zivilisierte Welt
vielen Dank
Thomas Hacker war das FDP-Fraktion
medienpolitischer Sprecher dort und sie
haben es wahrscheinlich gemerkt haben
andererseits wissen sie es ohnehin schon
zum Etat von Bundeskanzleramt und
Bundeskanzler gehört auch der Etat für
die Beauftragte der Bundesregierung für
Kultur und Medien Claudia Roth deswegen
spielt hier auch Kulturförderung und die
Stiftung Preußischer Kulturbesitz
beispielsweise eine Rolle in den Reden
zu in dieser Generaldebatte Sepp Müller
ist der nächste Redner stell einer der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
Unionsfraktion
die scheinbar diese Koalition
zusammenhält ist der Kit der Schulden
fast 500 Milliarden Euro neue Schulden
das nimmt diese ampelregierung auf das
sind so viele Schulden wie die
Bundesregierungen zwischen
1949 bis 1990 insgesamt aufgenommen
haben das geht zu Lasten unserer Kinder
und Enkelkinder hier kann ich nur den
Kopf schütteln Herr Bundeskanzler
Deutschland kann wesentlich mehr nicht
mehr Schulden sondern mehr Unterstützung
ein positives Momentum an Unterstützung
gibt es für den Osten mit dem
Bundeshaushalt tatsächlich es wird
zusätzliches Geld für eine Pipeline
zwischen Rostock und Schwedt aufgenommen
das war es dann aber auch schon und
dabei gibt es doch so vieles mehr was
ihr lieber Ampel auch mit wenig Geld
verbessern könnt dieses Land ist
gegängelt von Bürokratie es braucht eine
Entbürokratisierung und ein schnelleres
und effektiveres Planungsverfahren wo
ist euer Sommerpaket diese Lösung ist
nicht nur unkompliziert diese Lösung
kostet kein Geld es kann doch nicht sein
dass wir einerseits innerhalb von acht
Monaten ein lng-terminell in die Nordsee
rammen auf der anderen Seite schaffen
wir es aber nicht innerhalb von acht
Monaten eine zusätzliche Pipeline
zwischen Rostock und Schwedt in die Erde
zu bringen da müssen sie handeln Liebe
Bundesregierung
hier steht nicht nur die
Energiesicherheit für ganz
Ostdeutschland auf dem Spiel nein es
steht die Energieversorgung für ganz
Mittel und Ostdeutschland auf dem Spiel
die Sie zu verantworten haben Herr
Bundeskanzler ich sehe schon jetzt die
verblüfften Gesichter Anfang nächsten
Jahres wenn die Preise an der Tankstelle
durch die Decke gehen
vorausgesetzt es kommt bis dahin
überhaupt noch aus jedem Hahn Sprit
diese Regierung ist nicht in der Lage
dazu die infrastrukturellen
Voraussetzungen zu schaffen das Schwedt
ab dem 1 Januar 2023 auch weiterhin
ausreichend bedrohölversorgt werden kann
in einem deutschlandfunk-interview vom
Juni diesen Jahr dieses Jahres kündigte
Wirtschaftsminister habe ich an die
Kartellbehörde mit ausreichend klauen
und Zehen auszustatten Minister Habeck
hat angekündigt möglichst schnell
Vorschläge zu einem schärferen
Kartellrecht vorzulegen
bis heute funktioniert in der Umsetzung
davon nichts und wieder nichts im Juni
das ist möglichst schnell Herr Habig
nach ihrem Zeitverständnis fährt die
Deutsche Bahn pünktlich wir werden in
energiepolitisch schwierigen Zeiten
übergehen wenn kein russisches Öl mehr
in Deutschland ankommen doch ihre
ampelregierung vorneweg die
bundesaußenministerin Annalena baerbock
spricht öffentlich davon ich zitiere nie
wieder Öl nie wieder Gas aus Russland
das halte ich für falsch es wird eine
Zeit nach dem Kriegstreiber Putin geben
darauf müssen wir vorbereitet sein es
braucht nicht nur eine china-strategie
nein wir müssen Griff schnellstmöglich
einen Russland planen griffbereit in der
Schublade haben was ist wenn endlich
dieser verbrecherische Angriffskrieg
vorbei ist was ist wenn Putin im
Dezember hoffentlich nicht mehr im Amt
ist werden wir dann wieder Öl und Gas
aus Russland beziehen wollen ist es
sinnvoll Russland in die Arme von China
zu treiben ist es sinnvoll insbesondere
den von Deutschlands und deren Industrie
auf energiepolitisch unsichere Füße zu
stellen lassen Sie mich beim Thema
Energiesicherheit eines nochmal ganz
klar betonen Habeck mit ihrem Ziel
bereits 2030 aus der Kohle auszusteigen
gefährfern sie nicht nur die
Energiesicherheit Ostdeutschlands sie
stellen tausende von Arbeitnehmerinnen
und Arbeitnehmern vor ungewisse Zukunft
die SPD sagte vorhin Herr Mütze nicht
sie stehen an der Seite der
Gewerkschaften sprechen Sie mit den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der IGBCE was
erzählen sie eigentlich diesen
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer deren
Zukunft sie so leichtfertig auf Spiel
setzen ihr Minister Habeck hat es nicht
einmal geschafft das vorgesehene
Gutachten zum Kohleausstieg 2038 zum 15
August diesen Jahres vorzulegen
drei von vier betroffenen Bundesländern
Kollege mitzunich von der SPD sind im
Osten sie warten auf eine Antwort
tausende Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer warten auf eine Antwort
wir brauchen alle uns zur Verfügung
stehenden Energiequellen wir sollten uns
neuen technologischen Möglichkeiten wie
der Nutzung und Speicherung von CO2 als
Rohstoff nicht verschließen so
verhindern wir ein Blackout der
Industrienation Deutschlands unabhängig
von dieser Gefahr ist es doch
bezeichnend Herr Habeck das sind eine
Umfrage der Industrie und
handelskammerhalle Dessau alle befragten
Unternehmer zum ersten Mal seit 20
Jahren eine negative Zukunftsprognose
gezeichnet haben alle Befragten seitdem
diese Ampel am Werk ist sehen wir
wirtschaftlich dunkelste Zeiten auf uns
zu wollen da sagt nicht nur die Union
und nicht nur ich um eine Stimme von der
Handelskammer zu zitieren aus offenbar
ideologischen Gründen riskiert die Ampel
lieber dass sich die Wirtschaftskrise
vehement verschärft so der
Geschäftsführer der IHK Halle Dessau
packen sie an deutschland kann mehr wir
als cdu/c videofraktion haben dazu eine
Idee wir haben einen Plan vorgelegt
senken die sie die Steuern für
Unternehmer und Unternehmer auf 25
Prozent setzen sie sich für berufliche
Weiterbildung ein und setzen Sie sich
lieber Staatsminister Schneider endlich
für den Osten ein wir brauchen die
Pipeline von Rostock nach Schwedt damit
es in Schwedt ab 1.1 weiter geht für
Ostdeutschland für Mitteldeutschland das
ist der Plan deutschland kann mehr
[Applaus]
Sepp Müller war das für die
Unionsfraktion hier mit seiner Kritik an
dem
Haushalt auf ihn Antworten direkt kann
und Achim Post der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzender der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren
lieber Kollege Müller ich hoffe sie
sehen es mir nach wenn ich so gut wie
nichts richtig fand was Sie gesagt haben
ich nehme ihn aber und das ganz ernst
gemeint ab dass sie die Sorge um die
Zukunft unseres Landes antreibt und
umtreibt dass sie eine andere Sichtweise
haben als das was die Bundesregierung
macht und das zeichnet ja solche
Debatten in diesem Parlament aus das
kann man wenn ich nach ganz rechts außen
gucke nicht von allen Rednerinnen und
reden dann sagen da ist es unter
Formulierung wie der Niedergang
Deutschlands das Ende des europäischen
Abendlandes in Niedergang der deutschen
Kultur und generell das Untergang
Deutschlands nicht zu machen und ich
glaube lieber AFD dass sie von
Demokratie nicht viel halten das weiß
ich schon
ja liebe AFD ich bin nicht ich bin nett
ich weiß dass sie von Demokratie nicht
viel halten von Deutschland von diesem
Land von unserem Land verstehen sie gar
nichts liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
denn dieses Land
dieses Land dieses Land Deutschland
zeigt jedes Tag aufs Neue was in ihm
steckt und was in seinen Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern steckt mit Leistung Einsatz
Engagement gerade in Zeiten wie diesen
sehe ich Millionen von Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern und Beschäftigten die jeden Tag
was leisten und dafür sorgen dass wir
diesen Haushalt überhaupt verabschieden
können liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sonst hätte man nämlich keine über 450
Milliarden Euro für diesen Haushalt 23
und in diesem Haus gibt es wenige
jedenfalls nicht in der Ampelkoalition
bei den meisten der Kollegen der cdu/csu
auch nicht bei der Linkspartei auch
nicht die negieren die leugnen dass wir
schwierige Zeiten haben dass wir
konkrete Probleme haben und deshalb ist
es gut dass wir diese Bundesregierung
haben die packt diese Probleme nämlich
an
hohe Kosten für Energie sehr hohe Kosten
vor Energie wir gucken nicht tatenlos zu
wir legen 200 Milliarden Euro auf den
Tisch des Hauses und begrenzen den
Anstieg der Energiekosten
schwierige Lage in vielen Familien in
Deutschland ab dem ersten ersten
230 Euro für jedes Kind in Deutschland
das ist eine ganze Menge und das ist
eine ganz praktische Verbesserung der
Lebensbedingungen von vielen Familien in
Deutschland
dann zu dem was diese Bundesregierung
insgesamt leistet sie haben die
Bundeswehr vorhin angesprochen ich war
per März war es die 100 Milliarden ich
finde es lässt sich sehen wenn man in
einer sehr schwierigen Zeit 100
Milliarden Euro extra zur Ertüchtigung
und Verstärkung der Bundeswehr ausgibt
und diese Bundesregierung diese
bundesverteidigungsministerin macht das
übrigens wir haben am Anfang des Jahres
lange darüber geredet was ist eigentlich
mit Schutzausrüstung mit Schutzkleidung
jahrelang hat die
Verteidigungsministerin haben die
Verteidigungsminister der Union ist
nicht geliefert im April diesen Jahres
2,4 Milliarden Bestellung durch dieses
Verteidigungsministerium liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und diese Bundesregierung dieser
Bundeskanzler liefern nicht nur in
Deutschland sie liefern nicht nur für
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger hier sie
schieben auch in Europa was an die
übergewinnsteuer die zufallsgewinne die
kommt die darüber reden wir nicht manche
reden darüber die können das wird
abgeschöpft ganz praktisch und konkret
zugunsten des Haushaltes zugunsten der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in diesem Lande
die Vorschläge wie die Europäische Union
wir haben viel über Industriepolitik
geredet wie die Europäische Union mit
Deutschland an der Spitze besser werden
kann bei batteriezahlfertigung bei
erneuerbaren Energien bei Wasserstoff
das zeigt doch wie wichtig es ist dass
Deutschland eine aktive Rolle in der
Europäischen Union spielt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und wenn wir
darüber reden über Europa Einblick
weiter nach Bali das was der
Bundeskanzler in seiner
Regierungserklärung heute erzählt hat
und erklärt hat ist doch ganz klar seit
Elmau seit dem G7 Gipfel hier bei uns in
Deutschland haben wir eine konsequente
Politik betrieben vom Länder wie Indien
Südafrika Ägypten ganz praktisch näher
ranzuführen an das was hier bei uns
diskutiert wird sie waren am Anfang sehr
kritisch sehr kritisch was Abstimmung in
der Europäischen Union und auch was
Abstimmung in den Vereinten Nationen
angeht jetzt sieht das ganz anders aus
sie haben klar erklärt in Bali auf
diesem
G20-Gipfel wie schwierig sie den
Angriffskrieg Putins finden und wie Sie
ihn verurteilen das gleiche gilt für
China was wurde hier geredet die
China-Reise des Bundeskanzlers ein
Skandal die china hatte des
Bundeskanzlers sei falsch es wäre ein
Skandal wenn er nicht hingefahren wäre
denn nur mit dieser Reise haben wir die
klaren Aussagen der Chinesen bekommen
dass sie atomkriege verurteilen und
scharf verurteilen und deswegen
herzlichen Dank Herr Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz
zusammengefasst diese Bundesregierung
diese Ampel dieser Bundeskanzler handeln
sie handeln für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern in Deutschland sie machen das
richtige in der Europäischen Union und
sie machen das richtige weltweit gut
dass wir sie haben schönen Dank
das Wort hat die missbarkaden für die
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in Deutschland
haben wir Dekaden gebraucht um die um
uns an die Realität zu gewöhnen ein
anwanderungsland zu sein und das obwohl
wir mit den gewaltigen
generationsübergreifenden
Integrationsleistung der Gastarbeiter in
Generationen und später mit den vielen
tausenden geflüchteten vor den Kriegen
dieser Welt so viele gute Gelegenheiten
gehabt hätten dazu wir hatten zu wenig
Orte des Ankommens wir hatten
Reaktionen auf rechte Gewalt in Mölln in
Rostock und in Solingen die Verschärfung
des Asylrechts fahren Deutschland wollte
gar nicht dass Menschen hier ankommen
mittlerweile haben wir erkannt dass wir
ein Einwanderungsland sind dass wir ein
Einwanderungsland sein wollen ja ein
Einwanderungsland sein müssen seit
Jahren
seit Jahren sprechen wir davon dass wir
mehr Zuwanderung brauchen und was das
bedeutet wenn wir diese Lücken die wir
haben diese Zahlen die wir erreichen
müssen nicht füllen können an jeder Ecke
wird uns Personal fehlen und das wird
unser Leben bedeutend verändern eine
Lande Wirtschaft wird zu längeren
Lieferzeiten führen wir werden Probleme
bekommen in der Pflege und den
Zusammenbruch des Rentensystems auch das
kann eine Folge sein und die Ampel
liefert nun die notwendigen
bundespolitischen Weichenstellungen auch
in diesem Haushalt
statt Menschen über Jahre in
kettendungen zu drangsalieren geben wir
Ihnen eine Chance auf Bleiberecht und
leisten damit auch ein Beitrag zu
Bekämpfung des Arbeitskräftemangels die
Ampel hat die frühere Arroganz der die
Fehleinschätzung zu Attraktivität von
Deutschland auf Fach und Arbeitskräfte
und die die vielleicht auch nicht
ausstrahlt endlich abgelegt es ist ein
Irrtum zu glauben man müsse nicht viel
tun und man müsste auch nicht viel
leisten und man könnte sich gleichzeitig
die besten der besten aussuchen die alle
Schlange stehen in Deutschland arbeiten
zu können und mit dem Haushalt und den
Mitteln die wir jetzt hier beschließen
werden stellen wir uns zum ersten Mal
eine Realität die Bedeutung dass wir in
Konkurrenz sind mit anderen Ländern um
Arbeits- und Fachkräfte und das andere
Länder in der Lage sind noch besser auf
die Bedürfnisse von Migrantinnen und
Migranten einzugehen dass sie weniger
Schranken haben und weniger
Restriktionen und dass wir jetzt mehr
Teilhabe und mehr Zukunftschancen bieten
möchten und werden
aber ehrlich gesagt auch mal ganz plump
wir können die besten Gesetze dieser
Welt schreiben wenn in Bautzen
geflüchteten Unterkünfte Brennen der
wehren sich syrische Ärztinnen und Ärzte
überlegen ob sie nach Deutschland kommen
oder ob sie da nicht vielleicht doch
lieber noch Neuseeland oder nach Kanada
ziehen
und ein weiter so dieser Mix Signals wo
wir je nach Stimmung fühlen und auch
nach Tagesordnung MigrantInnen und
geflüchtete entweder an Bahnhöfen
beklatschen oder ihre Unterkünfte mit
Molotow-Cocktails bewerfen können wir
uns nicht leisten und ja es sind
unterschiedliche Leute aber die
Anschläge und die Angriffe reißen die
Arbeit vieler und die
Integrationsbemühungen noch von noch
mehr einfach ein wenn wir das einfach
hinnehmen
und auch die Arbeit von den vielen
Menschen die sich um
ausbildungsplatzvermittlung und
arbeitsplatzvermittlung kümmern die
diese stark begleiten werden mit Füßen
getreten wenn wir abschieben wenn wir
Menschen abstiegende integrationsmetik
sind und vielleicht sogar ein Ausbildung
sind wir brauchen Signale die positiv
sind wir brauchen eine gemeinsame
Kraftanstrengung wir brauchen gute
ambitionierte Bundespolitik aber das
alleine reicht nicht wir brauchen auch
eine Politik in den Ländern in den
Kommunen die das unterstützen wir
brauchen auch sie liebe Union dafür
investieren wir also gemeinsam in eine
Willkommenskultur und gemeinsam die
Stärkung von antirassistische Arbeit wir
müssen raus aus dem Modus Migration
hören und Problem denken die
Willkürlichkeit der gesamtdeutsche
Stimmung zu Migration ist wankelmütig
sie ist paradox und ehrlich gesagt sie
ist auch viel zu aufgeregt für die
Tatsache dass Migration eine Konstante
in der Menschheitsgeschichte ist
eine konstante auf die wir schlicht
angewiesen sind vielen Dank
viel Spaß
für die Bündnis Grünen ist hier unter
anderem auf den
fachkräftemenge Mangel eingegangen ja
natürlich ist das schon längst wichtig
für Deutschland im Menschen auch
zu werben dass sie nach Deutschland
kommen mit ihrem Wissen Gerald Ulrich
spricht nun für die FDP-Fraktion
liebe Gäste und Besucher zu dieser Zeit
der Debatte ist es immer etwas schwierig
noch ganz neuer Aspekte in den Raum zu
werfen ich würde es trotzdem mit einigen
Dingen probieren wir sind in einer Krise
und wir stehen eventuell auch an dem
Rand eine Rezession und die Frage ist
doch wie kommen wir dort wieder raus
meine persönliche Meinung und auch die
Meinung meiner Fraktion ist wir kommen
dort nicht mit verzichten als dauerhafte
Lösung heraus deutschland ist und bleibt
eine Exportnation und was uns trägt das
sind die Freihandelsverträge
Gott sei Dank kann ich dort sagen
verabschieden wir ja in Kürze ceta sehr
wichtig sind auch die anstehenden
Handelsabkommen mit Chile Mexiko und
Neuseeland und auch Merkur werden wir zu
einem Abschluss bringen
extrem wichtig ist aber für uns ein
Handelsabkommen mit den USA ich glaube
wir haben uns dort einige Jahre lang mit
falschen Argumenten herumgeschlagen wir
haben uns mit chlorhühnchen
herumgeschlagen anstatt um die
wirklichen um die wirklichen Probleme
aufzunehmen die dort sind und ich denke
dass wir gerade mit dem schon seit
einigen Monaten in Kraft gesetzten
Inflation Redaktion hat nun sehen dass
die Gegenseite auf uns zurückfällt wenn
wir ein Freihandelsabkommen mit den USA
hätten wäre dieser Akt für uns kein
Problem vor allem auch für unsere
Wirtschaft nicht
was wir brauchen ist dass wir der
deutschen Wirtschaft keine weiteren
Fesseln anlegen sondern für Entlastung
sorgen
vor wirtschaftlichen Erfolg liegt
deswegen auch immer die Forschung und
wenn ich gerade sehe was wir mit dem
besserstellungsverbot in Bezug auf die
gemeinnützigen
Forschungseinrichtungen tun kann ich
Ihnen nur sagen wir brauchen dort eine
Lösung und ich bin den zuständigen
Ministerien dort auch wirklich dankbar
dass im Moment nach dieser Lösung
gesucht wird und ich glaube wir stehen
dort auch einigermaßen kurz vor dem
Durchbruch und bekommen das auch hin
denn in Ostdeutschland sind diese
kleinen gemeinnützigen
Forschungseinrichtungen der eigentliche
Kern des Transfers von der
Grundlagenforschung in die Industrie
wir sollten uns doch wirklich klar
machen es geht hier nicht um mehr
Haushaltsmittel es geht hier um
Freiheiten und um nichts anderes
Wachstum setzt sich aber auch immer in
einem funktionierenden Wettbewerb fort
diesen Wettbewerb müssen wir Ideologie
frei gestalten wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass das Recht auf einen fairen
Wettbewerb auch wirklich genutzt wird
was wir auf gar keinen Fall brauchen ist
eine
ideologische ist eine ideologische
verbremmung von
wettbewerbsgesetzen deshalb sind wir
jetzt auf dem Weg zu einer
Fortschreibung einer
GWB-Novelle die wir auch dazu nutzen
wollen dort wirklich dafür zu sorgen
dass es in aller erster Linie um den
fairen Wettbewerb geht und nicht um die
Regulierung des Wettbewerbes ich würde
das für ein sehr großes Problem halten
wenn wir das tun ein weiterer Punkt um
die Wirtschaft am Laufen zu halten das
ist der Treibstoff dieser Wirtschaft und
dieser Treibstoff ist Energie das werden
wir in allen Bereichen erleben deshalb
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass dieser
Treibstoff auch in Zukunft bezahlbar
bleibt und dass er vor allen Dingen
ausreichender Menge zur Verfügung steht
auch da brauchen wir auch viele Gebieten
weiterhin Forschungen
[Musik]
mein letzter Satz deshalb lädiere ich
dafür dass wir wirklich eine
technologieoffene Forschung in allen
Bereichen haben auch in der Kernkraft
auch im Wasserstoff und auch bei den
synthetischen Kraftstoffen danke
Gerald Ulrich hat Dir gesagt das ist
nicht ganz einfach ist in dieser
fortgeschrittenen Debatte noch neue
Punkte anzubringen er hat allerdings
einen Alleinstellungsmerkmal hier im
Bundestag denn er hat als einziges Ampel
Mitglied damals gegen die
mindestlohnerhöhung auf 12 Euro gestimmt
Christiane schenderlein jetzt für die
Unionsfraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen in vier Tagen ist der erste
Advent die ersten Weihnachtsmärkte
öffnen viele von uns hoffen auf
besinnliche Tage in der Familie und doch
ist die Zeit von Krisen überlagert die
besonders auch den Kulturbereich
betreffen der dringend auf Unterstützung
des Bundes angewiesen ist es gibt große
Sorgen Energiekosten Inflation
Arbeitskräfte Mangel die
Kreativwirtschaft der Kreativwirtschaft
fehlt es an Sicherheit für 2023 geplante
Konzerte werden bereits wieder abgesagt
das ist bitter leider gibt die
Bundesregierung bislang keine
ausreichenden Antworten auf die Notlage
der kreativen bereits im August hat
kulturstaatsministerin Claudia Roth
energiehilfen für Kultureinrichtungen
angekündigt heute drei Monate später und
kurz vor dem Winter ist immer noch nicht
klar wie und an wen
die Welt fließen soll
angekündigt wurde dass dafür Restmittel
aus dem Sonderfond für
Kulturveranstaltungen in Höhe von einer
Milliarde Euro verwendet werden sollen
und man auch bei der Ausschüttung der
Gelder auf der Struktur der Sonderfonds
aufbauen will gegen diese Pläne oder
besser gesagt diese Zweckentfremdung
haben wir allerdings frühzeitig Bedenken
geäußert zum einen brauchen die
Kulturveranstalter weiterhin finanzielle
Unterstützung aus diesem Sonderfonds und
zum anderen hat er sich als unglaublich
bürokratisch erwiesen die Mittel sind
nicht bedarfsgerecht abgeschlossen die
viel bessere Blaupause wäre aus unserer
Sicht das Programm Neustart Kultur denn
hier wurden die Mittel über die Verbände
passgenau administriert ein Segen für
viele private sowie öffentliche
Kultureinrichtungen und Kulturschaffende
und auch bei den energiehilfen muss der
Kreis der Hilfeempfänger weit gefasst
werden das heißt die privaten Kulturorte
und freischaffenden mit einschließen
und die Hilfe muss sie jetzt fließen und
eben nicht rückwirkend in ein paar
Monaten
erste private Kultureinrichtungen haben
bereits angekündigt über den Winter zu
schließen und das heißt wir dürfen keine
Zeit verlieren die Bundesregierung muss
endlich Nägel mit Köpfen machen die
Kultur braucht nicht nur Pläne sondern
Planbarkeit die Kultur braucht Hilfe die
auch helfen
nachdem
die Kreativwirtschaft monatelang auf den
Ansprechpartner bei der Bundesregierung
warten musste werden jetzt immerhin
Gespräche geführt diese müssen aber
Ergebnisse liefern denn sonst bleibt es
beim Smalltalk Geld ist offensichtlich
da die Erhöhung des kulturhaushaltes
begrüßen werden im Bereich Auswärtige
Kulturpolitik hingegen wurde kräftig
gestrichen allein bei den
Goethe-Instituten satte 25 Millionen wir
haben beim parlamenter im
parlamentarischen Verfahren gemeinsam
etwas auffangen können der Fehler bleibt
gerade in Zeiten internationaler Krisen
ist die Arbeiter Goethe-Institute
wichtiger Denner und das gleiche gilt
auch für die Deutsche Welle unserem
auslandsender Propaganda und
Desinformationen nehmen zu doch die
Ampel hat unseren Antrag auf zusätzliche
Mittel für den russischen ukrainischen
Angebote abgelehnt und das gilt eben
auch für das Zukunftsprogramm Kino es
ist das wichtigste Vorprogramm zum
Erhalt der Kino Infrastruktur
das Kino sterben ist in vollem Gange
adaia ist es notwendig jeder zusätzliche
Euro notwendig und gut angelegt sie
verkaufen den Kulturpass für 18-Jährige
jetzt als in großen Wurf aber wenn es
kein Kino mehr gibt hilft auch der Pass
nicht mehr ganz abgesehen davon dass die
100 Millionen Euro noch gar nicht
freigegeben sind weil kein Konzept
vorliegt nur die schöne Überschrift die
gibt es bereits und dann
gibt es auch mal ganz schnell 70
Millionen Euro für ein Programm
Strukturen Stärken ab Achtung im Jahr
2025 was für ein falsches Verständnis
von Weitsicht dabei fehlt es unseren
großen Kultureinrichtungen von
nationaler Bedeutung an Geld das
Bundesarchiv sendet Notrufe die Stiftung
äußere Kulturbesitz hat durch den
Reformen Prozess mehr Bedarf und auch
die Grundfinanzierung beim Humboldt
Forum ist nicht gesichert die Bilanz
nach einem Jahr regieren fällt
jedenfalls ungenügend aus Anzahl der von
der Ampel eingebrachten Initiativen in
den Bundestag zwei das grundsätzliche
Problem dieser Regierung zieht sich
leider auch durch den Kulturbereich die
Probleme werden gesehen es sind Lösungen
angedacht aber die Umsetzung steht aus
gut gedacht noch nicht gemacht das
trifft es
ich zitiere Herrn Kilb in der FAZ vor
einer Woche als Claudia Roth im dezember
2021 ihr Amt antrat tauschte sie die
Führungsebene ihre Behörde fast
vollständig aus die meisten ihrer
persönlichen Referenten stammen wie man
hört aus der Parteizentrale der Grünen
und hatten mit Kultur bislang wenig zu
tun Zitat Ende nicht verwunderlich also
dass die meisten Vorhaben aus den
Koalitionsvertrag bislang auf dem Papier
stehen die Antwort der Bundesregierung
auf meine Nachfrage zum geplanten Plenum
Kultur im Juni war das weitere Vorgehen
wird im Laufe des Jahres geklärt jetzt
haben wir November also vor rot liefern
sie und binden sie vor allen Dingen im
Bundestag transparent ein das erste Jahr
ihrer Regierungszeit
ist vorbei und zum Glück für die Kultur
kommen maximal nur noch drei Jahre dazu
das Wort hat die Kollegin Verena Huberts
für die SPD-Fraktion und Verena Huberts
ist eine der stellvertretenden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der
Sozialdemokraten im Deutschen Bundestag
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sind jetzt
als Ampel ein Jahr dran und ich habe mal
so ein bisschen Revue passieren lassen
wie dieses Jahr war und ich persönlich
komme aus der startup-welt habe ein
Unternehmen gegründet und wir im Startup
haben so ein Motto gehabt dass uns
manchmal geleitet hat und das hieß
Wetter dann perfekt also was bedeutet
das einfach mal ins machen kommen nicht
tausendmal drüber nachdenken auch
nachjustieren wenn man mal Fehler macht
und wirklich Dinge umsetzen und dann
habe ich mir gedacht wie war eigentlich
jetzt so mein erstes Jahr hier im
Deutschen Bundestag
und so ein paar Parallelen kann ich
irgendwie doch auch schon sehen es ist
natürlich ein krisengebeuteltes ja und
es erfordert dass wir hier schnelle
Entscheidungen treffen es erfordert dass
wir große Themen miteinander klären und
es sind auch die einen oder anderen
nachrunden die ich als Parallelität hier
aus meinem vorherigen Leben schon
identifizieren durfte können wir auch
gerne sein lassen
Haushalt der atmet auf der einen Seite
Zukunft und das ist sehr wichtig denn
wir haben ja gerade zwei Modi die
parallel sind wir haben die Krise die
wir mit allem was wir können bekämpfen
mit abwehrschirmen und noch viel mehr
aber die Zukunft die wartet doch nicht
auf uns und die kommt jetzt und das ist
auch schneller und vor allen Dingen ähm
schneller und entschlossener als wir es
uns vielleicht auch mal vorstellen
konnten und deswegen ist es auch wichtig
dass wir investieren in Arbeitsplätze in
diesem Land in eine klimaneutrale
Wirtschaft aber dass wir auch ganz genau
miteinander schauen wo haben wir denn
Zukunftsbranchen in unserem
Industriestandort Deutschland und ich
bin in Haushältern sehr dankbar dass wir
das Thema jetzt hinbekommen haben
gemeinsam wer sich damit noch nicht
auseinandergesetzt hat wir als
Europäische Union wir haben ja die
Möglichkeit besondere Branchen auch
besonders zu fördern und die
Gesundheitswirtschaft wo wir doch mit
biontech vorne mit dabei sind wo wir
doch gezeigt haben dass wir nicht nur
die Apotheke der Welt sind sondern dass
ich Forschung und Innovationen in diesem
Land lohnt da müssen wir doch dabei sein
und da gehen wir jetzt unter anderem mit
Frankreich auf diesem Weg für eine
zukunftsweisende Wirtschaft für aber
auch neue Arbeitsplätze in diesem Land
und ja man muss auch raus aus der
Komfortzone man muss Entscheidungen
treffen und vor allen Dingen
Zielkonflikte lösen
zum Beispiel ist das günstigste Produkt
nicht immer das klimafreundlichste oder
ich möchte gerne Windenergie aber bitte
das Windrad doch nicht bei mir im Garten
diese Regierung diese ampelfraktion die
geht endlich mal die Brücken und bringt
die Perspektiven zusammen denn in diesen
Zeiten kann es doch nicht sein dass die
Individuen die individuelle Interessen
die alle richtig und berechtigt sind
aber das kann uns nicht aufhalten wie in
der Vergangenheit sondern wir müssen
Lösungen finden wie es endlich mal
vorangeht in diesem Land und dafür sorgt
diese Ampel
und das zeigt auch die Art und Weise wie
wir regieren wir haben zum Beispiel mit
dem Bündnis für bezahlbares Wohnen mit
unserer bauministerin auch mal da die
Perspektiven an einen Tisch gebracht das
waren über 35 von der Bauindustrie der
Bauwirtschaft den Naturschutzverband den
Mieterschutzbund auch endlich den
Wohnungslosen und wir haben uns auf 180
Maßnahmen plus geeinigt und da nicht nur
sechs Monate miteinander Kaffee
getrunken und nächste Woche geht schon
weiter und Frau Ministerin ich bin Ihnen
sehr dankbar dass wir dieses Thema Dach
über dem Kopf klimaneutral aber auch
warm auch wenn es hier gerade kalt ist
ich sehe sie in ihrem Schal aber da
müssen wir alle mit auch ran denn ich
finde die Zeiten erfordern auch dass wir
hier miteinander Lösungen finden und das
Bündnis für bezahlbaren wohnen im
Kanzleramt ist so ein Beispiel wie diese
Ampel die Fragen löst im Querschnitt
miteinander und vor allen Dingen
zielstrebig
perfekt kann für mich auch eine
Überschrift sein dieses ersten Jahres
wir machen wir gucken nicht ewig
drumherum und ja wir korrigieren uns
auch wenn wir einmal nicht richtig
gelegen haben und in diesem Sinne
wünsche ich mir eine konstruktive
Mitarbeit für ein solidarisches aber
auch für ein fortschrittliches
Deutschland vielen Dank
das Wort hat der Abgeordnete Matthias
Helfrich Matthias Helferich war Mitglied
der afd-fraktion ist nun allerdings
fraktionslos sitzt noch beratendem
Ausschuss für Inneres und Heimat meine
Damen und Herren Kulturen sind
Organismen Weltgeschichte ist ihre
gesamtbiographie lehrt uns Oswald
Spengler wenn wir die Biografie
vergangener Kulturen schauen sehen wir
dass es immer die gleichen Entwicklung
waren die zu ihrem Niedergang führten
das römische Reich ging an der
Völkerwanderung zugrunde während Ostrom
dem Einfall von Hunden standhalten
konnte wurde die weströmische
Gesellschaft durch Zuwanderung zersetzt
doch auch die verteilungsung
Gerechtigkeit im römischen Reich führte
zu dessen Auflösung knapp ein Prozent
der 50 Millionen Bürger Roms teilten den
Reichtum unter sich auf die Elite der
Grundbesitzer Staatsbeamten und Militärs
lebte dank der hohen Steuereinnahmen aus
dem Provinzen im Überfluss die römische
Elite neigte zu Exzessen die ihre
Urteilsfähigkeit trübten und die
Verteidigungsbereitschaft Rom schwächten
Vetternwirtschaft und
Selbstbedienungsmentalität ließen den
Sinn für die restpublica bei den
Politikern verblassen und während sich
das römische ist Tablet an citrusholz
Tischen erfreute gönnt sich die
Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht
täglichen und Teppiche für Ministerium
und hohe von 100.000 Euro während die
patricia-familien ihre Angehörigen noch
in der Spätphase Roms mit hochdotierten
Staatsämtern versorgten verhelfen die
Grünen der schlepperorganisation von
Vizepräsidentin
zu Millionen und während Caligula im
wahren sein Pferd zum konsulante an
nennen sie den dating-app als Beruf
grünen Sven Lehmann zum querbeauftragten
und die Deutschen hasserin
pferdeattermann zu Anti
diskriminierungsbeauftragten insgesamt
42 Sonderbeauftragte samt sondern Gehalt
leistet sich die Ampel auch und gerade
um das eigene Milieu zu versorgen
verstehe sie nicht wenn sie die ganze
Schreiben mit der Maske auf und während
man sich früher als Herrscher in
steinmeißen ließ sucht Superminister
Harbeck ein hochfotografen für 400.000
Euro anstatt endlich die
Verteidigungsbereitschaft unserer Truppe
herzustellen wächst nur das Heer an
flüchtlingsprojekten bei der
migrationsbeauftragten Sie alle für
Deutschland in den Untergang aber eins
sei ihnen versprochen es gibt noch
Widerstand in unserem Land der es nicht
zulassen wird dass Deutschland an ihrer
Dekadenz stirbt vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Abgeordnete Helferich wir sind hier in
einer Debatte und es steht Ihnen
natürlich zu Kolleginnen und Kollegen in
ihrer Arbeit zu bewerten zu kritisieren
zu belobigen und so weiter aber ich
bitte Sie sich erstens einer
parlamentarischen Ausdrucksweise zu
fleißigen und zweitens nicht dritte hier
mit einzuziehen
das war mal der Hinweis von
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Petra Pau und
damit geht es weiter mit Erhard
grundelndem medienpolitischen Sprecher
von Bündnis 90 die Gründung Bundestag
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren ich
kann die Zukunft nicht sehen aber ich
spüre dass sie uns ganz genau beobachtet
das ist ein Zitat der Songwriterin Annie
Clark besser bekannt und ihrem Künstlern
Sand Vincent und ja wir sollten uns von
der Zukunft beobachtet fühlen denn die
Zeit in denen wir glauben durften wir
könnten unser Tun vor der Zukunft
verbergen ist endgültig vorbei wenn wir
als kulturpolitiker:innen mit dem
Protesten der letzten Generation in den
Museen und Galerien konfrontiert sind
und vielleicht darüber die den Kopf
schütteln müssen wir uns trotzdem
vergegenwärtigen dass wir heute an der
Schwelle stehen wo viele Gewissheiten
der Vergangenheit sich in Auflösung
befinden
auch in der schönen Welt der Kunst oder
vielleicht gerade dort
Populismus taugt nicht zum Regieren
schreibt Carolin Emke zuletzt in der
Süddeutschen Populismus taugt in einer
Demokratie auch nicht zur Opposition wer
die last generation mit der RAF in
Verbindung bringt in einem Atemzug nennt
der verhöhnt letztendlich die 34
Mordopfer der RAF das einzige was sie
Herr Dobrindt beherrschen ist das
kleinkarierte einmal eins der Hetzer und
Spalter und das schreibt mir auf
schärfste zurück
um die Welt der alternativen Fakten mit
der Realität zu konfrontieren braucht
unsere Demokratie eine freie Presse als
Grundlage für faktenbasierte
Meinungsbildungsprozesse ein Diverses
Medienangebot dafür brauchen wir
unerschrockenen Journalismus der die
Finger in die Wunden legt das gilt für
Deutschland und das gilt im Angesicht
von Krieg und Unterdrückung Verfolgung
über unser Land hinaus und darum fördert
die Ampelkoalition mit rund 2,3
Millionen Euro Projekte zur Stärkung der
Medienvielfalt Projekte für
Journalistinnen und Journalisten sowie
Programme zur Stärkung der
Medienkompetenz darum haben Annalena
bärburg Claudia rot und die Ampel
Schutzprogramme für Verfolgte
JournalistInnen im Exil aufgesetzt denn
die Stimmen der christlichen
berichterstatte innen werden auch dort
in ihren Herkunftsländern dringend
gebraucht
meine Damen und Herren zur Zukunft
gehört auch der Blick in die
Vergangenheit darum ist uns als Ampel
die Erinnerungskultur so wichtig wir
fördern die Digitalisierung von
dokumentationsbeständen zum
Nationalsozialismus wir stärken die
Stiftung Denkmal für der ermordeten
Juden Europas um einen Ort der es
Erinnerns und der Begegnung mit Polen zu
entwickeln und wir stärken wir dass er
Ihnen vor Ort
in München war die Bauhaus Synagoge in
der Reichenbachstraße jahrelang
verborgen hinterbauzäunen und
Plastikplanen
1970 starben hier bei einem
Brandanschlag auf das angrenzende
jüdische Altenheim sieben Menschen der
Brand wurde im Treppenhaus gelegt so
dass eine Flucht vor dem Feuer unmöglich
war die unfassbare Tat ist bis heute
nicht aufgeklärt die Täter nicht gefasst
nun erhält die Synagoge in München als
Ergebnis 44% der Gesamtausgaben für die
Renovierungskosten aus dem
Bundeshaushalt so kann die Bauhaus
Synagoge wieder als selbstbewusstes
Zeichen jüdischen Leben sichtbar sein
eine Entscheidung für dich der
Ampelkoalition sehr dankbar bin meine
Damen und Herren erinnern heißt nicht
nur historisieren oder schön reden was
nicht schön ist wie zum Beispiel das
unsägliche Spruchband an der Kuppel des
Humboldt wurde uns also überschritten
sie die Interessen ihrer Kollegen was
ein Haus der Weltoffenheit sein will das
hat der Spruch hat nichts mit
Weltoffenheit zu tun
es gehört drüber der erste Artikel des
Grundgesetzes die Würde jedes Menschen
ist unantastbar vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und den nächsten Redner haben sie heute
eventuell schon bei uns gesehen Thorsten
frei war heute morgen schon im Interview
beim Kollegen er hat schärfer jetzt
spricht er hier im Plenum
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
vor ziemlich genau einem Jahr ist diese
Koalition aus SPD FDP und Grünen
gestartet damals durchaus mit hohen
Erwartungen und der Spekulation das
werden die Themen auf der Agenda sein
was wird der Stil dieser Koalition sein
und auf wessen Konto werden mögliche
Erfolge einzahlen heute ein Jahr später
sehen wir etwas klarer und wir sehen
dass die inhaltlichen Erfolge dieser
Koalition ausgesprochen mager sind und
das dokumentiert sich auch in dem
Haushaltsplan den wir heute
verabschieden werden oder den wir diese
Woche verabschieden werden dort wird
deutlich dass sie auf die zentralen
zukunftsherausforderungen letztlich
keine plausiblen Antworten haben
was wir
aber eben schon sehr schön sehen können
ist dass insbesondere bei zwei Partnern
dieser Koalition massive
glaubwürdigkeitsverluste in den
vergangenen zwölf Monaten eingetreten
sind und ich will das gerne an zwei drei
Beispielen
illustrieren der Glaubwürdigkeitsverlust
der FDP der ist ziemlich klar zu
datieren es ist der zehnte November
2022 als 82
FDP-Abgeordnete hier im Foyer des
Plenarsaals blaue Karten in die Urnen
werfen und damit einem von SPD und
Grünen vorangetriebenen Gesetz zur
Mehrheit verholfen haben dass den Geist
eines bedingungslosen Grundeinkommens
geatmet hat
ja Sie müssen
sie müssen sich anhören sie müssen sich
bedauerlicherweise anhören weil genau so
ist es Herr dürr und die Tatsache dass
sie und dass sie im Grunde genommen die
Verantwortung dafür
dass es Akzeptanz für den Sozialstaat
gibt bei denen die in finanzieren die
jeden Tag zur Arbeit gehen die mit ihrem
Geld diesen Sozialstaat erst ermöglichen
dass sie die Verantwortung dafür an den
Bundesrat und an cdu/csu ausgelagert
haben und wir möglicherweise heute Abend
zu einem guten Ergebnis kommen das ist
der Glaubwürdigkeitsverlust der FDP ich
kann mir das gut vorstellen dass sie das
nicht hören mögen aber der Wahrheit ins
Auge zu sehen ist der erste Schritt zur
Besserung und ich kann Ihnen sagen es
gibt auch noch einen zweiten Punkt wo
man den Glaubwürdigkeitsverlust der FDP
deutlich machen kann und das wird in
dieser Woche sein nämlich wenn sie ihre
blaue Karte einwerfen um ihre Zustimmung
zu diesem Haushalt zu dokumentieren ja
476,3 Milliarden Euro sie werden die
Zustimmung geben zu einem Haushalt der
nur formell die Schuldenbremse einhält
aber in Wahrheit der Haushalt ist der
die meisten Schulden zu verantworten hat
in der Geschichte unseres Landes sie
können es natürlich abstreiten sie
können
sie können rechnen wie Sie wollen die
Wahrheit ist dass sie genau dafür die
Verantwortung zu übernehmen hatten und
der Glaubwürdigkeitsverlust der entsteht
insbesondere dadurch dass sie noch vor
einem Jahr sich damit gebrüstet haben
dass Sie erfolgreicher bei den jungen
Wählern gewesen wären als alle anderen
Parteien die Wahrheit ist dass sie mit
dieser Schuldenpolitik letztlich die
Steuern für zukünftige Generationen
manifestieren überall wo sie in ihrer
Bilanz eine Entlastung markieren werden
sie auch eine Belastung markieren müssen
und das zahlen die Kinder und Enkel in
zukünftigen Generationen dafür tragen
sie die Verantwortung und jetzt könnte
man ja sagen die FDP ist in ihrer
Wirtschaftspolitik geprägt durch eine
angebotsorientierte Politik ja ich
kritisiere das nicht das ist positiv das
ist richtig wir haben das heute auch in
anderen reden schon gehört wie sehr das
täte nur sie handeln nicht danach gerade
bei der Frage in der Energiepolitik
beispielsweise bei der Frage der
Laufzeitverlängerung für Kernkraftwerke
hätten sie die Chance gehabt zu beweisen
dass sie in der Lage sind eine wirklich
angebotsorientierte Politik zu machen
denn es ist doch vollkommen klar dass
auf einen angebotsschock mit einer
Ausweitung der Kapazitäten reagiert
werden müssen was haben sie gemacht sie
haben sich von den Grünen belügen lassen
und Feiern es als Erfolg des im
streckbetrieb die Atomkraftwerke bis
Mitte April weiterlaufen sollen das ist
kein Erfolg lieber Herr dürr sondern es
ist im Grunde genommen ein Armutszeugnis
und wenn man die Rolle der FDP
zusammenfassen wollte in dieser
Koalition dann könnte man es mit zwei
Worten tun Schlimmeres zu verhindern ich
finde das ist wirklich kein
ambitionierter Ansatz
und darüber hinaus
kann man auch sagen ja mit der FDP ist
jetzt auch gut
mit der FDP ist jetzt auch gut
und man könnte
man könnte im Bereich der Energiepolitik
natürlich auch das notwendige zu den
Grünen sagen denn die Grünen haben auch
viel Glaubwürdigkeit verloren in den
letzten 12 Monaten ja wenn sie mal
schauen wie sie sich gegründet haben vor
gut 40 Jahren wo sie darauf gesetzt
haben dass es keine zynischen Umgang mit
Wahrheit und Politik gibt wo sie auf
Werte gesetzt haben auf Wahrhaftigkeit
und dann beispielsweise ich habe gerade
davon gesprochen ein Gutachten im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium und im
Bundesumweltministerium so zurecht
geboten wird dass es am Ende zur
Ideologie der Grünen passt dann ist es
etwas was mit Glaubwürdigkeit und
Wahrhaftigkeit nichts mehr zu tun hat
und genau das haben sie zu verantworten
sie haben vorhin eine Rede gehalten wo
sie davon gesprochen haben dass die
Grünen die Partei wären die auf
Technologie setzen würden dass die
Grünen die Partei werden die verhindern
würden dass wir von einer
industrielokomotive Lokomotive zu einem
Industriemuseum werden sie sind dafür
verantwortlich dass die Energiepreise in
die Höhe geschossen sind in die sie
geschossen sind und zwar weil sie auf
eine Verknappung des Angebots dringend
es ist ihre Expertin Veronika Grimm an
der Spitze der Wirtschaftsweisen die
beispielsweise vorgerechnet hat dass man
durch eine längere Laufzeit der
Kernkraftwerke die Preise und bis zu
12,1% senken könnte das ist die Wahrheit
und deswegen verantworten Sie diese
Politik und weil es auch um die
Einsparung von Millionen
CO2-Emissionen geht muss man eines sagen
die Grünen sind keine klimaschutzpartei
die Grünen sind eine schnöde
anti-akkw-partei das muss man wirklich
sagen und das was notwendig wäre in
dieser Situation das wäre wirklich eine
angebotsorientierte Politik dann müsste
man auf Kapazitätsausweitungen setzen
dann müsste man in der
Arbeitsmarktpolitik die richtigen
Akzente setzen dann müsste man für
Entbürokratisierung sorgen für eine
Beschleunigung von Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren und zwar nicht nur
bei lng-terminals da haben sie ja
bewiesen dass es geht es gilt für den
gesamten Energiebereich es gilt für die
Verkehrsinfrastruktur dort tut es Not
und dort machen sie es aus ideologischen
Gründen nicht das ist die Wahrheit und
er sollten Sie ins Auge sehen und das
gleiche gilt dass wir unseren Standort
wettbewerbsfähig für die Zukunft machen
wahrscheinlich werden wir jetzt das
erste mal in einer Krise sein aus der
wir nicht gestärkt hervorgehen nicht so
wie in der Vergangenheit warum weil sie
nichts tun um unsere
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit verbessern es ist
ja nicht nur so dass Gas und Strom in
Deutschland zehnmal so viel kostet wie
in den USA auch schon vor dem russischen
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine waren wir
drei Mal teurer als Frankreich nehmen
Sie die Steuerpolitik sie schreiben in
ihrem Koalitionsvertrag fest dass es
keine Unternehmenssteuerreform geben
soll schauen Sie sich mal an wo wir
heute stehen wir sind nicht
konkurrenzfähig und mit dieser Politik
werden sie eben nicht durch die Krise
durchsehen werden sie eben nicht unseren
Standort stärker machen sondern ganz im
Gegenteil herzlichen Dank
die ja Generalkritik kann man das schon
nennen von Thorsten frei hier auch an
den Grünen die er nur als
anti-agw-partei keine klimaschutzpartei
unter anderem
bezeichnet hat und jetzt wird es
wahrscheinlich doch ein bisschen ruhiger
wieder werden
wenn der Krise spricht für die
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn man im
Schluss seine Haushaltsdebatte redet
dann gibt einem dass die Möglichkeit
noch mal das ein oder andere
zusammenzufassen und ich muss sagen das
was ich heute von den Rednerinnen und
Rednern der Union erlebt habe das ist
ungefähr wie Argentinien gestern man
ging ambitioniert auf Spielfeld man
verdiente sich man enttäuschte alle
Erwartungen am Ende Standard eine leeren
Händen da das ist kurz zusammengefasst
dass die Union heute uns hier
präsentiert hat
dann muss ich sagen bin ich schon bei
einigen der Beiträge gerade aus der
Union heute schon wirklich erstaunt ich
kann nur sagen das sind herausfordernde
Zeiten für unser Land das ist nicht
einfach die Entscheidungen sind nicht
einfach ich bin aber froh und dankbar
dass diese Bundesregierung diese
Ampelkoalition in diesen schwierigen
Zeiten handelt und dann vernehm ich ja
immer von der Union diese vermeintliche
Wirtschaftskompetenz die gesagt wird und
da muss ich mal ganz deutlich sagen wenn
wir märz im März gefolgt werden wenn wir
gefolgt werden ein gasimport Stopp für
dieses Land zu verhängen sie hätten
diesen Industriestandort sie hätten die
energieintensive Industrie vor die Wand
gefahren es wären Betriebe schon
insolvent und pleite gegangen das ist
die Wirtschaftskompetenz der Union und
ich muss erstmal deutlich sagen wer
solche Vorschläge macht wer so etwas
raushaut für den gilt nicht Opposition
ist Mist für den gilt Opposition ist
muss und auch noch lange so will ich das
mal ausführen
und dann lieber Thorsten frei zum
Bürgergeld da muss ich ja schon sagen
was ich da in den letzten Wochen von
ihnen erlebt habe was da teilweise
kolportiert worden ist da kann ich an
vielen Stellen nur den Kopf schütteln
das zynischste was ich aber erlebt habe
in den vergangenen Wochen das war eines
dass man sich gegen das Bürgergeld
stellt dass man versucht hat eine
Bevölkerungsgruppe die wenig verdient
gegen eine andere auszuspielen das mag
man alles selbst beurteilen ob man das
machen muss ich fand das schlimm aber
wenn sich dann der bayerische
Ministerpräsident für PR-Fotos in die
Tafel begibt und feststellt dass mehr
Menschen Hilfe brauchen in diesen Zeiten
dann aber gleichzeitig gegen das
Bürgergeld poltert und dann gleichzeitig
ihre Fraktion nicht mal den Mindestlohn
zustimmen damit arbeiten mehr wert ist
damit Menschen gut verdienen können da
ist das unglaubwürdig und schadet auf
dieser Debatte in diesem Land
und ich will das auch noch mal sagen die
Ampelkoalition hat auch in der
Energiepolitik schwierige Entscheidungen
in diesem Land treffen müssen aber dass
wir Entscheidungen treffen müssen und
dass wir auch bei dem Ersatz von Gas so
viele Entscheidungen ich will das mal
formulieren eine Operation am offenen
Herzen im Laufen Betrieb machen mussten
das ist doch auch dem geschuldet dass
wir jahrelang beim Ausbau der Nr 9 waren
Energie nicht vorangekommen sind dass
wir es nicht geschafft haben den
Leitungsbau gerade Richtung Bayern
voranzubringen das sind Fehler aus 16
Jahren die sie auch mit zur verantworten
haben und wenn man dann sagt 16 Jahre
sind nicht so schlimm gewesen wie diese
Ampelkoalition dann kann ich mir nur
sagen sie leben im Wolken wollten
Kuckuck sein es ist gut dass die
Ampelkoalition dieses Land regiert das
ist gut das Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
die Verantwortung hat und nicht ein
Oppositionsführer mit vermeintlich
zugedachter Wirtschaftskompetenz vielen
Dank
das Wort hat der Kollege Stefan Seidler
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin moin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich freue mich
heute als ein Vertreter des
glücklichsten Bundeslandes Deutschlands
vor ihnen stehen zu können die
Schleswig-Holsteinerinnen und
Schleswig-Holsteiner wussten es
natürlich schon lange aber nun haben wir
es einmal mehr schwarz auf weiß aber
woran liegt es denn dass die Menschen
laut glücksatlas von letzter Woche in
Schleswig-Holstein wie auch die Menschen
ins Skandinavien glücklicher sind als
sonst wo am Wetter am Fisch nein ich
denke es liegt an einem bestimmten
Lebensgefühl einer nordisch gelassenen
Offenheit die sich auch im Umgang mit
unseren Minderheiten ausdrückt der
Schutz unserer Minderheiten ist etwa
auch in der Verfassung
Schleswig-Holsteins verankert denn wir
wissen die minderheitenbereichern unser
Kulturleben und unsere Gesellschaft und
deshalb bin ich auch sehr dankbar dass
wir die kulturinvestitionen im hohen
Norden und besonders die
gesellschaftliche und Arbeit der dehnen
und Friesen in den
Haushaltsverhandlungen im Parlament
stärken konnten das fördert die Vielfalt
und stärkt die Demokratie in unserem
Land meine Takt Schule an die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier im Hause
die dies zusammen mit uns ermöglicht
haben die Menschen im Norden sind nicht
nur glücklicher sie sind auch
klimaforreiter vielleicht sind sie auch
deshalb so glücklich unser Norden geht
bei der Energiewende voran und zeigt wie
man nachhaltigen sauberen und günstigen
Strom produzieren kann deshalb liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der CSU
weil sie bei der Energiewende das Feld
von hinten aufrollen sie sind immer gern
nach Nordfriesland eingeladen wir zeigen
Ihnen gern wie das mit dem Wind und mit
dem Wasserstoff geht
was wir allerdings nicht tun werden ist
unsere kostbare Natur den Risiken des
frackings auszusetzen da kann Markus
Söder vom Norden fordern was er will
meine Partei der ist es wie lebt
Fracking im Norden klar ab wir dürfen
jetzt keinen neuen Quellen für fossile
Brennstoffe mehr erschließen unser Ziel
muss es sein von fossilen Brennstoffen
wegzukommen deshalb sind wir auch gegen
eine neue dauerhafte landgebundene LNG
Infrastruktur die aktuelle Energiekrise
darf nicht zu neuen langfristigen
Investition in einen Energieträger
führen den wir eigentlich überwinden
müssen denn mit Blick auf die
Infrastruktur dürfen wir uns nichts
vormachen eine vollständige
Weiternutzung der lng-anlagen für grünen
Wasserstoff wird es nicht geben das geht
physikalisch schon gar nicht es gilt
bereits jetzt fokussiert zu investieren
in Windkraft in den Netzausbau und in
grünen Wasserstoff gerade beim LNG sehen
wir doch wie schnell es gehen kann das
wird heute mehrfach gesagt im Mai war
Baubeginn in Wilhelmshaven im kommenden
Januar steht das Terminal in Betrieb
Monate statt Jahre so muss es sein aber
ich frage mich nur warum klappt das beim
Gas und nicht bei den Erneuerbaren wir
nehmen in diesen Tagen hunderte
Milliarden Euro in die Hand und die
Energiekrise zu bekämpfen dass es
richtig und wichtig aber wir müssen beim
Klima in die Gänge kommen denkbar allen
Krisen die Klimakrise bleibt die
bestimmende Krise dieser Zeit und das
ist heute leider zu kurz gekommen vielen
Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
das Wort hat die Kollegin Tesla Jesus
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin lieber
Kollegen
was sehen Sie wenn Sie die Augen
schließen und an Kultur denken
Opernhäuser vielleicht sind sie auch
Bilder von Gerhard Richter von Warhol an
übergroßen weißen Wänden
ich möchte Sie einladen gemeinsam mit
mir jeden weißen Wänden mal für einen
Moment den Rücken zu kehren und Kultur
Jenseits Jenseits setzen zu suchen
wir werden wunderbare Graffitis in
Bahnunterführungen finden glänzende
laufsteger in boging Ballrooms Afro hair
Workshops bei denen Kultur-
wir können Kultur planen und dennoch
wird die Kultur ihren eigenen Plan
machen
für eine vielfältige Kulturlandschaft
ist es unabdingbar dass alle gesehen und
gehört werden nicht nur jene die es
gewohnt sind
und eine starke Lobby haben deshalb bin
ich Staatsministerin Claudia Roth auch
so dankbar dass sie mit dem Kulturpass
die Jugend in dem Fokus setzt für den
Kulturpass stellen wir der Bundestag 100
Millionen Euro bereit jede Person die
nächstes Jahr 18 Jahre alt wird erhält
ein kulturkapital in Höhe von 200 €.
damit ermöglichen wir endlich auch
Jugendlichen kulturelle Teilhabe
weitere 5 Millionen gibt es für den
Festival Förderfonds damit werden auch
kleine alternative Festivals gefördert
denn Festivals sind auch ehrenamtlich
organisierter Festivals wie das Open
Flair bei mir in Eschwege
eine Festival im ländlichen Raum das zum
wiederholten Male als bestes Festival
Deutschlands ausgezeichnet wurde
und es wird trotz der 20.000
BesucherInnen noch immer von dem Ort und
drüber hinaus ehrenamtlich gestemmt
bleiben wir im ländlichen Raum mit dem
Programm
zusammengestalten Strukturen stärken
werden wir rund 69 Millionen Euro für
die Jahre 25 bis 30 einstellen damit
wollen wir heute schon die Zukunft der
Menschen im ländlichen Raum sichern
mit diesem Haushalt
mit diesem Haushalt lösen wir auch unser
Versprechen aus dem Koalitionsvertrag
ein vergessene marginalisierte
Communitys mit unserer Kulturförderung
zu erreichen auch euch sehen und hören
wir wir fördern mit Silikon temporary
zum ersten Mal ein Ausstellungshaus dass
sich mit den Nachwirkungen und den
Kontinuitäten des Kolonialismus
auseinandersetzt hätte ich als Schülerin
ein Kulturhaus besuchen können dass dies
anbietet während einige Lücken
geschlossen worden das war schon lange
überfällig das packen wir jetzt an
vielen Dank
[Applaus]